This is Jocko podcast number one 81 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good Evening Echo. Good evening.
Get him out.
We were in Cambodia alone with no fixed wing aircraft.
Sal's eyes were as big as saucers.
I told Bubba to give me a claymore mine with a five second fuse I gave Bubba and
Foxville move quick signal. As we moved back to the LZ,
I stayed at the rear of the formation with sal and hastily with sal hastily
covering our tracks.
We'd only gone a short distance when sal hist beaucoup VC beaucoup VC.
I could see the pith helmets in the distance coming from the south.
I radioed the Green Horn at CNC helicopter and told them to return with their
gun ships and to pick us up at the primary LZ,
a s a p C and c said they'd have assets on site in 10 minutes or less.
Now, even 10 minutes seemed like a long time.
Twan and I fired our m 79 as to high bursts,
which slowed the NVA down for a few seconds.
Sao Open fire shooting shingles, single shots and moving backwards.
No longer bothering to cover our tracks.
I yelled to Bubba to move out at double time.
The race for life was on sow and sow.
Here's to hip and pointed north dam.
There were pith helmets and NVA uniforms coming at us from the north two and at
a dead run.
Yeah,
Sam and I placed a claim more behind a tree, pulled the fuse lighter and ran.
The NVA were now running and shooting wildly.
We sprinted to catch up to the team. As the claymore exploded,
the NVA kept on charging.
Sao quickly placed its claim more in front of a tree and ran.
While Twan and I provided covering fire,
we sprinted toward our team as the second claim or detonated.
We felt the blast on our backs as we ran as fork and BUBBA pushed toward the l z
hip Twan sow and I fired back using the immediate action drills.
The entire team had practiced for hours on end.
Twangy m 79 rounds were deadly effective.
Those combined with my m 79 rounds and the car 15 fire from hip and sal
temporarily starred, stalled the hard charging NVA troops.
We reached the LZ quickly in comparison to how cautiously we had exited it.
As the team set up a hasty perimeter hip placed another claim or in the path of
the NVA that were charging us from the south to the north Bubba ric declaim more
with a contact get nater on a trip wire.
As the tide of pith helmets flowed toward us,
Bubba and I opened fire with our m 70 nines and Sao and hip opened up on full
auto with their car.
Fifteens more NVA emerged from the smoke of the m 79 high explosive rounds and
tripped Bubba's claim more.
That's when the first Green Hornet gunship arrived.
I popped a smoke canister and directed a gun run to the west of our perimeter.
Within seconds, the gunship roar gunship roared in front of our perimeter,
shredding the NBA ranks, slowing them down for a few seconds.
The Green Hornets fired power was incredible. Finally,
the Green Hornet slick that inserted us into the target area arrived on the LZ
as close to our position as possible with his left door facing us.
The nose pointing north or northwest. Fortunately,
the air force had made it to us in less than 10 minutes.
The relentless NVA kept coming after us.
As Twan and I each on least one more.
M 79 high explosive round at the NVA bubble led the team toward the Air Force
Huey.
We always had an American lead the teams approach to an American helicopter to
avoid any confusion in regard to south Vietnamese team members on s t Idaho.
I fired the last claim war as the wave of NVA troops got in front of it.
Okay.
The last claim or blast gave me a few precious seconds to make it to the Huey
[inaudible].
In that right there is a another glimpse
into the insanity that John Stryker Meyer known as tilt lived through as a
special forces soldier in Vietnam,
a recon team leader for Mac v Sogs studies and Observation Group Command and
control. And if you have not listened to podcast one 80 yet,
then go listen to it.
Tilt was on that podcast and as soon as he walked out of the studio,
I knew that I needed him to come back as quickly as possible.
And I asked him and he graciously agreed. And here he is.
Once again, John Stryker Meyer tilt.
Good evening sir. Good evening. Yeah. You know,
you kind of mentioned that that one operation right there,
when you were out there facing three divisions,
after you got fat, dumb and happy on Thanksgiving Day with a big meal,
that then you guys rolled out into the field. Right? Indeed it did. And it has.
So how did that, how did that operation go now? Have you guys got inserted?
How did you end up in that situation where you're running away,
putting in five second fused claymores face the enemy? What was,
what led up to that? Well, we had a briefing the night before and um,
they were hyper concerned because the three NBA divisions,
30,000 men where Mia, Lily and the dia,
whoever else is out there had lost contact. So, uh, that night, uh,
myself and the CEO and S3 went over to maps, Liz reports,
audit Intel reports. We were up until after midnight.
So, so they, they came to you and said, hey, we're missing 30,000 men,
three divisions of NVA. At first. The third one we've gotten the CIA login,
we've got the dia, we've got spy planes and all that stuff. We can't find them.
So then they come to you?
Yeah. Okay. And you're like, cool, we got this. Oh yeah.
And at the time I was still a spec four and [inaudible] so, and I had,
I hadn't met the CEO yet. So the first thing was, he looks at me, he says,
you're an e four this is an e 89 bill at what WTF? I go, look sir.
Long story short, I said, look, I've run a bunch of missions up north.
We're here TDY. How can I help you? And he settled down. We looked.
Then we were up all night looking at those Intel reports.
And then they also had pictures that were from 70,000 feet.
We had never seen anything like that.
And my mom was a piano teacher and one of her students,
dad worked on lenses for aircraft to shoot from 70,000 feet.
He talked to me about my, as a young kid, I go, oh, that's really cool.
Well now I knew what he was working on and why he couldn't really talk about it
much. But they, that was the first time,
the SRS w ones we use overflights got it. And, and I say,
where'd the hell these come from? It cause I was like, this is mind boggling.
And used to seeing, you know, a little pictures close by people smile.
But for 70,000 feet we had a good estimate as to where they might be.
And they said, we can't tell you this stuff. Shut up. You don't haven't seen it.
And so we put it all together,
just try to Syria and we went in really on the ground a short while,
maybe an hour or so and then all hell broke loose.
And did you, didn't you,
you stumbled upon their camp or like a camp that they had recently left?
Yeah, well they have a, they would have waste stations along the way.
And so we walked into them before we found some,
but never would fire is burning. The one still had a Pato on it.
And so, um, and when we got back,
sound guy's estimated then one division had just left and they're point there
tell them it was what came back at us.
And the other from the north was just moving into the base camp. Ah,
little sandwich. Yeah. Little NVA Sandwich. There we go. And we were to,
we were to Bologna your basic balloon.
Yeah. Did you go into that one real heavy in terms of, is that,
cause I is, if I remember correctly from the book,
how common was it that you carried the five second fuses on the,
uh, we started doing that a month earlier, um, early part of November. I mean,
could, we had a couple targets where, um,
the numbers were just incredible when they came at us.
So I always wanted to have those just in case.
So here we took a few extra fuses. You know,
John had fuses and a sow and a fuck.
They all knew how to work those. And so, um,
here I said, because we saw how open area was,
we were used to triple canopy up north. And so now we're in Cambodia.
You could see three or 400 yards away,
maybe 500 yards WTF times to knees.
He the pith homeless run Natchez.
Whoa. How does it feel when you see the NVA in an open run towards your position
toward arms? Yeah. Good Lord. Deb was, it was an experience.
I'll take it to the grave with me. That's a nightmare is your worst one.
How did you, did you, did you in a situation like that, you're,
you're, you've got,
I mean thousands of potentially thousands of enemy soldiers.
Some of them are booze blatantly running towards your position.
What are you thinking in the back of your mind? Are you thinking, Hey,
we're not going to get out of this, are you just,
I know for me in my experiences, which are nothing come close to that,
but I was always just thinking about getting my job done. Like, okay,
this is what, this is the best thing I can do right now. Hey,
we need to put some people over here.
Let's get some machine gutters up on the roof.
I would never get to a point where I was or maybe I didn't have enough time or I
wasn't smart enough to think about what big consequences were coming.
But when you see,
when you see those helmets running towards you at port arms,
you've got to be thinking,
this isn't looking real good for this isn't looking real good. Full tilt.
And the bullet I had my first Jocko moment,
which was the good news is we found these fuckers.
The bad news is they're coming to kill my ass.
Really. It's like,
well, I'll play. We did our homework last night. This really worked out well.
Maybe a little bit too well. Yeah.
And just thank God for the Greenhorns Smith Day. Then get back to her,
which is only a question of time.
And they could, you would,
you would keep them on station gen for generally like for like 10 or 15 minutes.
Well, this is Cambodia. Everything was different there. First we had no, uh, uh,
no fixed wings. All we had was to helicopters,
but there were the greenhorns air force at that state at that point in time,
November 68 they were,
they had to stay to art Hueys they were the fastest.
They could carry more loads and or many guns. Uh,
I think they had mounted mini guns that they could handle manually.
Some of the early ones we saw were mounted and so the helicopters would have
limited maneuverability. But the one,
the year air force was just really on top of the game. Well that's what came in.
And when they came in with their mini gun runs,
I really bought us a couple of valuable seconds. Seconds.
They were common and you could see him as just like,
and I was looking at some pictures of you yesterday and you guys still had 20
round mags. Oh yeah. Which you went,
which you'd load out to 18 rounds cause you didn't want to compress the spring
too much and cause a jam.
Right. And we would have run over your mother to get one of those
don jobs. Yeah, man. Oh yeah.
It was, it was different.
So we always had at least 600 plus rounds all in the magazines that a couple of
strip bandoliers just in case.
Yeah. And you guys did make it out that time obviously. Um,
well yeah. And then you know here too, when we left,
the chopper pulls out and as we're lifting off the NVA come out of the jungle,
the thin jungle and it was muddy.
You had rained the day before and these guys are coming out there or at port
arms and they're trying to stop and the mud comes up from their boots just to
try to stop, come down to port arms. So mean a door gunner just,
and I forget it was sour. Fuck,
we're just getting these guys and they just stopped like a cartoon and they go
back, this is what happened.
It just blew these guys back into mud from their boots as going up into the
props as they're trying to stop and they hit him and these go back into the
jungle and we got the hell out of there.
It strikes me as strange because as I keep reading about the NVA, well,
I mean we know that these, you know, this is an insurgency,
these guys are looking to not fight when they don't have to. Right.
That's why it always surprises me in your, in,
in your stories how determined they were. Like those guys, hey look,
okay the Americans, they're getting on the helicopter, we'll let them go,
whatever, uh, we'll come back next time. You know,
we don't want to die right today cause we don't have to. We can wait,
we can wait 10 years or we can wait 20 years, you know, we go,
we're going to be here forever.
For them to have that kind of determination where they were just common in
common and convenance and like you said on the last podcast,
literally stacking up bodies so they could get to you.
That would've been just a crown jewel to capture a little,
a little special forces team. Oh, here. I mean they had to kill American award.
So if they,
if they confirmed that they killed one of us or got the body of a dead body,
they would get their killed an American award and they would get a bonus of some
sort, maybe ruled heroes up north
for the rest of their lives. Awesome.
Okay. So that book and we talked about on the last part, last podcast,
and I said it last time, we touched less than 10% of the book.
The stories are completely insane and you can get that book on Amazon.
Uh, you won't, but you've written, that's not the only book you've written.
You've written another one.
Another book is called on the ground and this book,
again, you're, it's, it's just the same level of, of insanity.
You feel strange for me to be sitting here talking to you because every time I
read a story, one of your stories, I'm like,
how's this guy making it out of this? Uh, there's,
you kick this one off with an interesting story. These guys, one of the,
it's you're not with them, but it's a recon team on the ground.
A guy named Watkins is in charge. Pat Walk-ins,
and they're set up on a road and they're doing a recon and I think they set up
an ambush to like a j and ambush to take out some troops,
but they end up with this massive NVA convoy. And when I say massive,
I mean massive. It takes hours to get by.
And there's people and there's trucks and there's bulldozers and there's tanks.
Yeah. And again, I've got to point this out. So we're probably talking,
you know,
a thousand enemy soldiers at least that are patrolling by you for an hour,
for three hours. They're walking by you.
And meanwhile you got a team of six guys, eight guys, something like that.
And it was seven or eight, I forget. But yeah,
and they're there and they're monitoring this.
And Pat was familiar with all the Russian tanks,
so he knew what the Russian tanks were and he had it all to you and tell
together. And the,
just one of those another night and SOG another night in socks.
So they're sitting there waiting and they,
they eventually they go by and uh,
and eventually now one of the,
one of the Indian soldiers that was working alongside walk-ins,
one of the members of the team was named wrong, r, O, n, g.
And he comes up after this convoy goes by, he comes up and this,
this is what happens. I'm going to the book here. Wrong city.
He'd been watching the road traffic just like Watkins and it had been taken,
taken, had been taken as taken with it as he was mean. He was like lost in like,
oh my God, I can't believe the summer stuff.
While he was staring at all the vehicles passing by a handed,
reached out and given his arm, Mashiach, a mountain yard soldier, one of those,
the NBA had pressed into unwilling service.
Said it's your time for guard duty.
Is that close to the enemy or why? That's nuts. Oh yeah,
completely nuts. The mountain yards, which you guys called yards,
the nuns, the south Vietnamese,
even sometimes former NVA soldiers.
What was it like? Who did you mainly work with?
What were the differences between the different groups?
There are different ethnic personalities and I know we didn't talk about last
time you talked about in the book, but those,
those different ethnicities didn't always get along. Oh No.
Especially when it came to playing poker apparently. Oh yeah. The cards games.
Cause I first, like the first few days at Fubu,
they had a poker game that went awry and, and uh, the Cambodian lost,
he goes to his room, gets a fry grenade,
comes back and dumps it on the Monty yards.
So we had an instant fireflight into compound. And you know,
you always going through the training, you turn about the different groups.
Well that case we had the Cambodians Monton yards nuns and in my team was south
Vietnamese,
which included at least four guys that came south in 54.
Uh,
when there was an 18 month truce where anybody that in north could go south with
thousands, did the navy had a special operation, would it,
has ships going up to NOI and shipping thousands of people south?
Nobody went north. Nobody wants to be up with the comedies.
But we had those had four of them Almighty and they were just outstanding
troops. And uh, so that was fooled by,
and his team was that brew, which was the lowest of the Monte Yard tribes.
Cute.
They couldn't throw a hand grenade where the shit but fearless and they hate,
they hate it. The North Vietnamese.
That's one of the key points in it and you talk about in the book is how much,
you know, what,
what the North Vietnamese had done to the mountain yards and how much they
fiercely hated them and how fiercely loyal they were to you guys. Oh yeah.
Macy troops. And uh,
they would just fight to the end and it was more than,
there's more than one guy who like a one zero who had,
we called them affectionally our little people. The little people said,
I'll take a bullet for you. That's how dedicated they were.
And they proved that over and over again over and over again. Now,
some teams had troubles, but we never had it.
Like on my team or with the freshmen, most majority of teams,
the s the little people took care of vetting their own.
So like when Idaho was liked out,
sal and Hep went out and recruited and there were young kids, 15 years old.
We brought on the team but they vetted him and we never worried about him so we
didn't have to worry about the friendly fire or what they call today with a blue
fire. Yeah. They call it uh, they call it
friendly fire. Yeah. There's just called, they have another,
they have another word for it too that I can think of what it is cause friendly
fires like a mistake. Right, right.
What we're talking about is when you know some of your own yeah,
it was one of your Taliban forces or one of your,
your local forces is actually a Taliban person in turns on your,
is actually a uh, Mati militia guy and turns on use of those things.
Those things are scary very because they build up trust and all of a sudden the
guy turns on you.
Cause early on sober eight camps had trouble with that with their, uh,
the Monte north had turned who had been a more loyal to the calmness for some
reason. But then there was, others had issues cause they,
they like special forces,
but they were pissed off working with the South Vietnamese and they didn't,
they were just, they don't kill. They would happy to kill South Vietnamese,
our allies or to commies up north. And sometimes you had to like,
guys don't, don't kill our allies. Not Today please.
But I'd never had that. My team was all south Vietnamese, all rock man.
So one of the, one of the other crazy parts of,
of this book that you open with or you start one of the early chapters is this,
this attack on fob four,
which was just sound completely, completely horrible.
And here's a quote from the book, the entire compound.
This is after this attack happens,
the entire compound was now a swirling battleground with dozens of small but
ready deadly Dyer firefights in progress.
It was difficult to tell the scantily clad Americans and indigenous personnel
from the enemy. And there was no command coordination,
just a lot of individuals struggling against uncertain and overwhelming odds.
The air was filled with enough chaos to the census. Screams, shouts, bullets,
dust, smoke, and the smell of cordite, burning wood, rubber and fuel.
And lastly, the smell of seared flesh.
And this, this attack
resulted in 17 special forces. Soldiers were killed.
And I don't know the number of, of indigenous forces that were killed,
but this sounded like just a complete, I mean,
obviously it was a big win for the enemy.
And what was your perspective on all that? Where were you when that happened?
I was safely ensconced and fob one because uh, uh,
fob four had opened at the end of 67 and a very,
at the base of a mountain.
And there's a whole lot of political reasons why they're at the base of a
mountain. But anyways, they're there. They had it,
a test attacked body Vietcong grant around Christmas time of 67.
And on August 23rd, after the dust settled,
the men who were there like pat walk-ins estimated that,
that that attack in December was a test to see what could,
they had minimal defenses up, minimal wire.
The internal security force was riddled with via comm.
And they planned this attack for over a year to sapper attack with the NVA
sappers as well as via Kong Holly train sappers and conventional troops that
went in just pouring the Loin Kloss and uh,
carrying a weapon or a Satchel charge and hand grenades. And, um,
so I was at food by the hit after midnight.
There's always a discussion about what time they hit.
And since then we've had a, uh,
military intelligence salsa came back and one of the people that we said was
70th as he's 16,
but still the highest number of green berets killed in one battle in our special
forces history. And, uh,
fortunately we had a recon team up on a hill on marble mountain at night that
took out the, uh, the mortars could,
the Amie were just dropping mortars off the mountain,
into the camp on top everything else
because they don't care about friendly fire. Speaking of friendly fire,
the enemy doesn't care. No,
they don't care if they're dropping mortars on their own people as long as
they're killing some of their enemies as well.
And some of them had their bandanas and said, we came here to die. And they did.
What did that,
what would the repercussions that went through your community after that
happened?
Uh, everybody, you know, you,
it's one thing to talk about being a hit by an enemy force at night.
They fight when they want to fight. That's a classic example of them doing it.
They planned it for over a year.
They even came in and took over the indigenous mess hall for final briefing in
the base that night before they launched the attack.
And so that's how well planned it was.
So they went in to the indigenous camp,
the friendly camp, and gave
their final briefing for the attack inside of the friendly camp.
Yup. And they had to have our loyal,
a indigenous truth that saw something suspicious. When he went up,
the NVA killed him right away and left her body's liner.
And so it was really well planned. They knew to camp. Um,
we had a promotion board. So, um, all of the,
at that time there was six f o bs, one through six.
This was fob for Indian Ang.
And so all of the people up for promotions came in that day.
Most of them stayed that night. On top of that, we had, uh,
they had monthly command and control briefing.
So every CEO as well as,
as as three or the XO from each of the fops was all at fob for,
and then the,
we had a command and control element that was based at the Denang air base and
they had just moved onto base,
so had increased population and they knew it and as the way they planned it and
they planned it on a night when there's no moon.
Yeah.
Got To uh,
always respect your enemy always. And then we always carried a weapon,
no matter where we went is wanting to be like fob one.
We had a good security there,
but even then you don't know because they be a comm would come and we found um,
mortar markers on the roof of the clubhouse and they had come in and walked it
out and there's part of their via condo come in and help do whatever was in
base. But they were also there marking targets for future mortar attacks on our,
on our compound. Yeah.
That would happen that my first deployment to Iraq,
I was in Baghdad and we would,
they would occasionally roll up guys that had their gps, you know,
the little contractors guys that did everything from empty out the
port-a-potties. There was guys that cut hair. These were just, you know,
there's, there was civilians,
Iraqi civilians that worked on the base and occasionally they'd get rolled up,
they'd look at their phone or look at their why, what are they carrying?
They'd have a gps with them and sure enough,
they're out there trying to figure out where you,
where's a good place to drop a mortar.
I actually like kicked all the contractors out of our compound completely.
And that's something that I had heard from the Vietnam vets was like, nope,
you don't, you don't know who's who. You just don't let them in.
And so when I showed up,
we actually move the port-a-potties outside of our compound.
We had to go outside if we wanted to. They were still in Americans, uh, area,
but they were not inside of our compound. So they,
so there was no locals inside our compound at all. Zero. That's what we,
that's what we did when I showed up. And that's why I did it because I was,
I had heard, hey look,
there's going to be people that will be gathering intelligence on you and if
they're in the compound, you can't,
you can't vet every single civilian that's going to come out there.
The contractors scary. It is. Yeah, I was, that's,
that is uh, the,
the g the chapter that you actually covered in two chapters cause it's such a
horrible, but
that's an incredible read to see what those guys went through. Oh yeah.
How many did you just go interview people? How did you get all that information?
Well, um, several of our guys, meth will be one where they're at at night.
So on the 24th after, by noon time, everything has settled down.
They had, you know, they have failed in their attack.
We had controlled at camp of relief forest from fob.
One went down led by Colonel Barr, Lieutenant Colonel Barr,
and they went through and cleaned up any of the left palm last pockets of enemy
soldiers.
And there was an appeal dubby camp right next to us and Nestle,
there was an effort to free that 500.
So POW is that we're going to break loose to come in to further help over on our
base. But a couple of key people made a key uh,
effort along that line to the north. The Stop, the uh, the uh,
pending escape of the NVA there. Please don't,
I'm at a tipping point. Oh yeah. Erection. There's a bit as good as a one amiss.
So anyway, that an answer to your question,
we had a lot of things in my mind and then we closed fob one in January,
went south. And so several the guys that had performed at night or survived,
we're all there. So I talked to him, she had mental notes and then, uh,
when I worked on the book,
we came back and I did a piece for soldier of fortune.
I usually wrote under a nom de Plume and we did a first story written about that
back in a day and a soldier fortune printer back in 80 sometime or early
nineties. So I use that. And then build on it.
And then John Peters to coauthor on that book, uh, on the ground.
He was there at night and he was in a hooch. He and uh, Doug God,
Shawl SF are too drunk from that night.
And like many of the people that were there and uh, but the young, uh,
Bill brick charged out of hooch,
it was gunned down immediately cause they had machine gun, uh, positions,
setups, anybody came out, they had gotten them down.
And that one element that was up on top of the mountain there. Yeah.
And there was, there was one American with multiple, uh, is that right?
There was one there. There's two, uh, ed ames was up there.
He was the one zero and the Larry Trimble was actually the one doing a lot of
the operational stuff cause uh,
aims was monitoring the radio and it was he,
Larry and his people that took out the mortars that night or the cast
[inaudible] would have been much higher. And then their indigenous said, hey,
we're going back down the next day, the next day. Cause Ed Ames went out, the,
the king became and lifted him out. They put it in replacement,
who sprained his ankle was something getting off the helicopters.
He could not move. But he, so he worked available.
Ly was the guy taking care of everything on top. And uh, yeah.
So he did said they wanted to go down that Dan and I said, well,
you may run into ambushes going down marble mountain,
because what we didn't know was underneath marble mountain, there is layers of,
of um, stories.
They had hospitals down there via conch training grounds, everything else,
which we learned about years later.
Right along with the Buddhist monks that rode down there, they,
they Kozik the peacefully. And so, uh, yeah,
they went down and Larry for a while was by herself.
Deer. Yeah. They got into a fire grave. Yeah. Those guys get a firefight.
They come back. Yeah. But when they left, he's up there by himself.
He's just low. Hey, I got this. And he's the lone ranger.
Your own ranger going to defend this thing until he's dead.
That was his attitude. That was, that's Larry freaking unbelievable. Oh yeah,
absolutely. You gotta get this book and read these, these parts. They're uh,
they're epic, epic heroism, I mean, and crazy and,
and incredible lessons learned as well. And I know you're not,
we're just talking about lessons learned and how easily lessons get forgotten in
the Milton that it happens in any organization but in the military for sure.
You know,
cause guys are going there to command for two or three years or maybe four years
and then they're somewhere else and then someone else comes in and different
experiences and no one agrees on what's right and what's wrong.
And next thing you know, you do, the lessons are gone. You forget them.
So these books right here capture some incredibly important lessons for anyone
on the battlefield or even close to it. Um,
I want to get down to kind of the end of your first tour here
and I'm going to the book.
When I win one April, 1969 arrived.
I was a conflicted man.
The end of my tour was slated for 27 April so far I'd avoided the short timers
attitude because after all it was Vietnam.
And we were engaged in guerrilla warfare across the fence. Nonetheless,
I couldn't believe I was still alive.
Okay.
I looked forward to going back to the world and yet I felt incredibly guilty
about leaving Sao hap and foc and the other men at CCN behind,
which is CCN is what they renamed FMI 44 I believed in the SF mission,
but how long could r t Idaho go on without a casualty?
We hadn't lost a man to hostel fire since May,
1968 when the previous incarnation lost six men in Laos,
r t Idaho had run a lot of missions, been in a lot of firefights.
It wasn't a stay behind team that schemed to remain in camp.
I was alive.
Thanks in large part to the skills and courage of Sao hip Twan and the other
Vietnamese team members as well as to the courage and flying skills of the
Vietnamese king bee pilots and the American pilots, the Marines and Scarface,
the judge and the executioner as well as TAC air pilots who always responded to
our calls for help.
We were alive because the recon gods at smiled on the reassembled r t, Idaho.
Somehow the magical elixir of trust, training, instinct,
guts, timing, and God's good grace had fallen into place.
There were other things that were collectively wearing on me.
Toward the end of my first tour of duty by April,
1969 both Lynn black and I were frustrated with having enemy soldiers shooting
us out of so many targets as the helicopters approached LZs for landing and when
we weren't in the field,
we found rt Idaho getting frequently assigned to guard duty,
a top marble mountain because black and I had continually butted heads with the
ramps to add insult to injury.
There conveniently were never any choppers available to air lift us to the top.
We had to hump all of our supplies ourselves,
which was still a dicey business in the light of all the VC activity in the
village to the south of the mountain and the in the caves. Deep inside it.
We always moved up marble mountain on full alert.
One on one such trip sal was training hung to run point hung earned his pay that
day as he found and deactivated more than a dozen booby traps,
including a claymore mine that had a pressure released firing device on it.
So you're sort of downtime like, hey,
we're back in camp. We're just going to pull a little easy duty here.
Just stand some guard duty. Oh, we got to go up to marble mountain. Oh,
there's no one to take us up there, so we're going to have to patrol up there.
And you're going up there and you find on your way up there more than a dozen
movie trece Oh yeah. That's trying to get to your guard duty.
Yeah. I guess that could wear on you a little bit
that that was significant day. We didn't sleep well that night.
And so this marble mountain, how long was the patrol to get there from base?
Well, it's close by and uh, we,
we would usually walk around to the south side of the mountain and there were
stairs that you go up before you get to the, uh,
trails cause it was so steep to get to the top that there's only certain number
of ways you could walk up. And uh, we, you know,
you always try to alter how you go,
but there's only so many times you can alter it. And so that data way we went,
so a sal and hung really earned their pay. I mean, he and they, they followed,
he stamps, but that had been me,
now Lynn's Lin was a little bit more sharp and keen eyed to me,
but that had been me, I would've been hamburger meat on that first claymore.
And so that stuff, like I said, it's wearing on you.
Obviously it would wear on anyone, but that's the end of your tour.
You get done with that tour. And we touched on this a little bit on,
on the last time, but I wanted to go a little bit deeper on you.
You're coming back to America after your first tour in Vietnam, how old are you?
Uh, let's see. 69, 23, 23 years old. And when you get back,
again touched on this a little bit,
but they assign you, they assign you to, um, like, uh,
a signal cut signal company.
Meaning you're not an operational guy and you're in with some and you're just
coming out of Vietnam and you're, you're, you're hearing people are saying like,
Hey, what do you, you know, was it even,
was it even there's guys that are of actively Avoiding v going to Vietnam?
Oh yeah. This is the 10th Special Forces Group. And, uh,
they had been in Germany since 52 and they had,
they were actively involved in a Cold War and those guys earned their pay.
Their, uh, in fact, one of the first books just came out on debt a,
which was there in a cold war. Um,
but this is a special forces unit.
So companies a through d were active e because of my Mos Camo.
Oh, cause you're radium. Radiomen that's a great a man. They stuck me there.
And, uh,
we had four or five platoons and there are new officers,
their butter bars, like right out of ocs,
they're young and they treated everybody like was basic training.
And my first thing was, excuse me, this is an SF unit, even though it's signal.
And so we had
signal the officers inside that platoon, they're not,
they're not SF guys, they're like communications officers.
You know what? I'm not even sure.
I just know they're young and dumb and not respected.
And then we had the power to other platoon swords.
Each one was fat now to shape and had avoided going to Vietnam and was proud of
it and made fun of me and a couple of guys from d company because we weren't
smart enough to figure how to get out of going to numb. I'm going like,
wait a minute, what are you wearing on your head?
And so we had some difficult moments dealing with those guys and ma.
And so we had routine training as civil company,
wood trucks and all this stuff to go and do these things. I said,
whenever we do one of these little practice runs for a weekend or a mission,
we will, when could,
we're going to get outta here and let everybody else do the KP and stuff.
And that just pissed everybody off auto more.
I pushed our young guys and pushed them hard in base. We did duties,
training, missions, you're out there three or four days.
All this is just Camo and uh, but the way we did it,
I can't even tell you the details now cause I just hated it. But we won.
We were the first ones back to the base. We had the most single contact,
all the criteria and we met and we beat the fat rents.
Now a n. N so you're back. Where, where,
where were you stationed at that point? Devons Massachusetts.
So then you've got gotta. I mean,
if some people that weren't ever in the military don't realize this,
but even when you're in the military, when you're back in America,
you go and interact with normal civilian. You know, you go to restaurants,
you go to bars, you, you live a normal life except for your job. You know,
whenever the hours you've got to work your job, then your living, how was that
like now you're just going out for a pizza on a Thursday night,
now you're going out to have some beers on a Friday night or a Saturday night.
How was that transition?
Um, it was difficult because actually we didn't transition,
basically hung out mostly with the SF guys up there because there's
Massachusetts, didn't know much about the small towns and um, I bought a four,
four, two w 30.
I had to get a job just to pump gas on weekends just to get actually cas and
hopefully be able to pay for the insurance. Did you buy it brand new? No.
Used even used. Oh yeah. That thing was expensive, Huh? Oh, it could go.
I blew it up on the turnpike at a 130 miles an hour. But uh,
it was a great car in between. And uh,
so I'm working and you know, what was your, what was your side job? Oh,
pumping gas.
They had local shell station at one of the little towns outside of Fort Devins
and the guy was a, um,
he was a World War II vet and he had put up a sign,
I bought gas and there's a sign help Juan. I say, Hey, I need cas.
Can I work for you on weekends or if I get a day off, he said, yeah, come on in.
So I was highly trained, I could do oil changes, I could grease him up.
And uh, it was fun. And uh,
you were Greenbrae special forces.
Vietnam just got done with your first tour
and you're pumping gas on the weekends. That had to be a little bit of a,
of like a tough thing to swallow.
It was, but you know, we swallowed it cause that's like I got to survive.
And at the time I was just,
I still had a sweet thing down south and so she was dealing some issues,
um, up there, this whole thing's falling apart. And Boston,
Boston was so anti military. I mean it was just peace freaks Galore.
I went to town twice now, I never went back because it was,
they could tell that we were in the military cause our hair was still shorter
than the average hippie in Boston. Not a good time.
So we just stayed with our guys. Um,
Durbars we had a few engagements in the bars, but uh, yeah,
I was glad to get out of there.
And you ended up getting in trouble for some of those engagements as far as we
did.
I'm told that the NPS came by cleared based the day before they got there and
uh, I can, that's all I know. Taking the fifth amendment on that one.
This is the SOG operation that will remain secret. Indeed.
So you are a little bit on the lamb, you were a little bit on the run. Yes.
And so you run to, uh,
to your, to this woman in d c is that where she is?
Oh yeah. At the Pentagon there was a woman in charge,
SF orders for Southeast Asia. Her name is Billy Alexander.
She's one of our saints, patron saints.
There was, there was a woman that,
that ran the officers that detailed the officers in the seal teams for a long,
long time. I want to say she did it for 40 something years and yeah,
I mean it's the exact thing like if you,
if you knew her and she was always great to me and I mean she was very nice to
me and she took great care of me probably because I was just lucky enough to
have some senior people that knew me and you know, put in a good word.
But she was always very nice to me.
But I saw what happened to some guys that maybe she didn't like so much or it
was rough. So it sounds like, you know,
you showed up with some flowers or bottle one she liked and you went,
this is independent in the puzzle. Pallets at the Pentagon. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Same thing. Yeah. Same thing. Yeah. This, no this won't. And like I said,
this woman was always super nice but she, she wielded a lot of power, you know,
in, inside, inside the seal officer community. Wow.
Cause if she didn't like you, well she was right in your orders.
And if she liked you, then you know, and was like, you know,
let a few more neutral than what, you know, she gonna do what she's gonna do.
But yeah, it sounded like Mrs, uh, Billy Alexander was, uh,
the same type of thing. Oh, he drove down all night,
got dairy right in the morning at Pentagon open, walked in.
This is before any metal detectors. Walked in and asked the guy where she was,
went down, gave it a one to flowers, please give me orders.
Came back at the end of the day, drove back all night.
How many people were just going all the way to the Pentagon to try and get
orders back to Vietnam? Oh, not many. I'm told. Not many,
but there were some,
there were all the SF guys that really felt more comfortable and they want it to
be there. And there's, there's a, I wish I could line up the stories,
but there's like Billy Wall and others that have gone to her over the years and
um, gotten their assignments they wanted, she took care of SF. Yeah, that's, I,
I've, I told this story the other day. I was kind of, there's an, there's,
so there's that woman who's the civilian that handles the detailing,
but then there's a, there's a,
a seal officer that would kind of work with her side by side.
He would get rotated out every couple of years. Well, when nine 11 happened,
I knew that guy and he was, he was a guy that I had worked for.
He was an officer and he was a great guy and I had a lot of respect for him and
we got along very well. And as soon as nine 11 happened, I called him and said,
hey, you know, I was going to college at the time. I said, cert,
please get me into college. Send me back to going back to a team right now.
I don't need to college, I'll finish it online or whatever. I said,
just please get me back to a team. And you know, he said, listen,
this war's going to last a long time.
But I was having a conversation with him a few months ago with him and his wife
actually. And I was saying, Oh yeah, no,
remember when I called you and I asked you to please send me? And he said,
he said everyone called him. And,
and it made me feel like that's pretty awesome. Like it wasn't like, you know,
I guess in my mind I didn't think I was special, but in my mind I thought,
you know, I really wanted to go. So did everybody else, every other seal that,
that Wa that wasn't in the Atta seal team. Everyone wanted to go when,
when the war happened every wanting to go do their part Esprit de Corps. Yeah,
absolutely. And uh, he was right.
The war lasted a lot longer than any of us thought it would.
So you get your orders back to Vietnam, you're,
what'd you do with the car? Well, but, uh, I had to get rid of four, four,
two traded in and got a little fat, five three speed on the, this is
survival vehicle, right? Yeah. And so, uh,
so I just parked at and dad took care of it while I was gone and, um,
um, so I went back to, went home and said, hey, I'm going back to nom.
I had no leave time cause I burned it all up previously.
And so went home and broke my mom's heart and told dad, gone gone back to my,
my sister ran me to the airport the next day and then, uh,
back to head and back to Vietnam. Yeah. Your mom must have been,
where'd your dad think? Uh, well, you know, dad was a,
I'll support your son and he was, to his credit, he never,
he never had an opinion, never asked him for an opinion because he had a,
he had deferment during the war family deferment cause he had to run the family
business.
And then my uncle flew over the hump so we had family service and um,
but he says, good luck if you need anything. Let us know.
And a mom was just like, she's a little bit more emotional,
but a tough old farm girl from Central Jersey, the Dutch farm girl, you know
Eddie. And even, even then,
did they know anything about what your last appointment was like?
No. No, we never talked about it. Just glad you're home. Yup.
Glad to be home. Where they had no idea what kind of,
what kind of situations you had been in. No, we really couldn't talk about it.
And I'm like, uh, I'll, if I missed it, you for not on air. But you know,
many years later my dad came up to me and say, you know,
I finally read across the fence and it says,
now I know why this guy came by and took our trash.
So he said, yeah. So they got the north guys, a tall black guy.
He come by and pick up our trash.
So he had to be from the FBI because they're checking my trash to see if I wrote
anything that is a violation of the, uh,
the agreement to be signed in Denang the 20 year agreement.
You won't talk about it, won't write about it. And they checked you on here.
So Dad and they, this guy picked up the transport at once.
Could Dad recognized her? He saw him down at the,
a postal office was near the FBI office. So he figured, oh,
the FBI guys check it on my Johnny.
Yeah, that's a sidebar. Yeah, no, that's,
that's, that's kinda crazy that they're putting all that effort to do that. And,
and yet you there, you're out pumping gas.
That's crazy to me. Yeah. Yeah. I gave a great Lou job though, buddy.
You came, you could even drop the grease. You need it. That's, yeah.
That's awesome. Yeah, that's crazy. You know, like,
that's uh, I guess when I'm older now, like, you know, when I was a kid,
I worked at fast food restaurants, you know what I mean? I can, and now I think,
man, I would not want to do that right now.
No. The funny thing was I had a little 25, like the Little Brownie,
25 boys carrying my pocket. This is Boston.
There's still some people that were like less than friendly up there. I said,
I hope I get robbed. I just want to kill them. You're a robber. But
Nah, it didn't happen. So what did happen? We got you back to Vietnam. Indeed.
So you get back to Vietnam. Going back to the book here,
the casualty rates for SOG,
recon teams were the highest for any unit in Vietnam.
We all had our close calls and thus each of us was given ample opportunity for
the truth of this observation to be in sized on his soul
non perhaps.
So more so than the young hard charging one zero of rt Michigan Sergeant Elden
Bardwell.
Okay.
No one who ever met him doubted his professionalism or determination.
He was not only meticulous when preparing his team for a mission and a fearless
leader went on the ground.
But he also possessed a biting wit and an absolute intolerance when it came to
fools and ramps,
fools and ramps being a redundancy and his way of thinking.
So this was interesting cause you, you, you talk about bars.
Well and in the story that you tell he they're,
they're out in an op and he finds a Avastin AK 47 vest and he wants it and he
wants the AK. These just found them laying around in a bunker or something.
So he puts on the vast and he gives the AK to one of his,
one of his [inaudible] guys and, and then he ends up getting shot in the chest.
And that, that uh,
vest actually saved his life cause it hit one of the magazines that was in the
vest. Correct. Crazy story. And what was interesting, so when I was in,
I was in Germany in 1998 I was stationed at naval special warfare unit two just
outside of Stuttgart. And My boss,
who is the commander of Naval Special Warfare Unit two,
he obviously directed to the guy that was in charge of Special Operations
Command Europe. And My boss, who I had a ton of respect for,
he's an incredible guy, a great guy, and taught me a ton.
He would tell me, hey, the, this, the use of soc commander, this guy,
he's awesome. His name is bars. Well, you would tell me stories about him.
He just absolutely loved the Bardwell and talked about him with the highest
respect possible. And, and he was, it was awesome. And I mean,
I knew about bars. Well,
I mean I basically learned about him initially from him. That's amazing.
Then it later on. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
I would read about him small world and what, uh, what, uh, you know, a,
a great guy. He was and what an epic soldier he was and what a great example.
And you know, so many people say he's the,
like one of the foremost examples of how you'd want to be as a soldier.
Just a great guy.
And I was lucky enough to have a little degree of connection too,
to have my boss work for him when, and he must've been,
he must've been a two star at the time.
I think it was a two star ballot at the time. So there he was. And He,
I think he did 40 something years, almost 40. Yeah. Couple of months shy.
Yeah. So that's pretty awesome to, to, uh,
to read about bars. Well. Oh yeah. Um,
you get to this point here where you're, you're talking about how crazy.
And I often try and explain how in combat unexpected things happen.
The things that you see, you can't make it up. Things happen are so crazy.
And you've got a section in here where you're talking about Lynn Black,
who's your running mate for a while? For a long time. Yeah.
Then when I left he took over the team and he ran it and when I came back I went
on a team. Then he,
we brought it up to speed with what the EO had changed in five months. Yeah.
And then we took turns and then they said, hey,
you guys got too much experience.
So Lynn went to did some more snoop and pooping and I took over Idaho again.
And, and this is when he's solo on the ground or you're not there.
He's not solo, but he's with his team. He's in Laos and they're on patrol.
They're deep in enemy territory, which is just like,
just the way you guys rolled. And He, you know,
the team starts to hear people following them.
And now they start stepping up their pace. They're trying to move,
they're trying to do things to disguise their trail and all that,
and finally they really like, okay,
we're definitely getting followed if the two days. Yeah,
after two days of being followed. Yeah, and so here we go.
Going back to the book, however,
before black could give the word to change course, the noises suddenly returned.
Only now it sounded as though a large number of enemy soldiers was headed
straight for them and the troops were not in the least trying to hide their
movement. This is it fought black.
The trackers have linked with reinforcements and they're about to try and
overrun us. He immediately told the team to head for the ridge form,
align and get ready for a fight.
Claymore mines were putting a quickly into place and black dug out the radio
handset in intact in anticipation of calling Covey black was totally convinced
he would soon be declaring a prairie fire emergency.
Back when black was with rt, Alabama, he had faced a matte.
He'd faced massive frontal assault waves by determined and VA,
so he knew what to expect and he knew what needed to be done.
Having moved the team up onto the ridge line,
he knew he had the tactical advantage. If the enemy wanted a bloody fight,
and it certainly sounded as though they did, the NBA could charge uphill and rt,
Idaho would give it to them.
Everyone had placed their weapons on full automatic and be gun and unbending the
metal pins on their hand grenades.
The ends were bent in order to keep the pins from accidentally being pulled to
the ring and hang up on a branch or something else.
High explosive rounds in the m 79 were replaced with rounds containing large
buckshot capable of blasting a devastating hole in any in the enemies ranks.
With everything in place and ready.
Our t Idaho faced the jungle and waited for whatever was coming.
The Frenchman called sight of something approaching,
but the vegetation was such that he couldn't get a clean shot at it.
He figured it was someone moving in a crouch because it only stood about four
feet off the ground.
He could see other similarly poised figures behind it all moving noisily toward
the team and a few more feet,
they would reach a point where the jungle thinned out and he'd figured he'd have
a good shot at them.
Like any recon man latour know had fought about such a moment.
The moment when an outnumbered team was forced to make a stand.
Thus like all the other rt Idaho members,
he was very tense but ready for anything, anything that is,
but what stepped into the clearing. He couldn't believe his eyes.
He found himself staring,
not an oriental gentleman in pith helmets armed with AK 47 but long armed hairy
reddish orange creatures with the decidedly human features.
It was a small band of Orangutans, probably a family of them.
They had been tracking the team out of natural curiosity,
trying to figure out what these hairless apes were up to in their territory.
Yeah, that's probably the happiest monkeys they ever saw.
Oh yeah, for sure.
I was in Sri Lanka and we got to see that, um, they, they uh,
you would hear them coming and they would be moving through the trees and it was
really cool. Uh, just, just how, but they, yeah,
you'd hear all this noise and it'd be a bunch of monkeys coming through the
trees and though we had that surround war. Yeah, we got online,
we were ready for the assault and just like we got overwhelmed by monkeys.
All right. Now we're getting to the point where you, so that was,
that was a Lynn black working on his own and now we're getting,
when you returned, when I returned to CCN at the end of October, 1969,
I immediately reported to sergeant major John Hobbes and asked if I could rejoin
Archie, Idaho.
He said that Latino had just completed his tour and returned state side.
There was an opening for an American and I could fill it,
but linen black jr is still the one zero and you two are both experienced one
zeroes.
I reminded him that I'd been away for five months and needed some time to get
back into the flow of things I added.
I'd be happy to serve as blacks one one for awhile because I respected his
judgment as I have poured. Now you go and meet with the team. As I approached,
I saw black and sal leading the team away from the range.
Once they caught sight of me,
their faces lit up and there was a rush of feelings of greetings.
As I shook black's hands, hand,
the team surrounded us dancing about almost like children and the good nature
taunts instantly begin flowing hot and heavy.
The gross insult being one of the most accepted ways a recon man can show
affection. I was subjected to a whole litany of them aimed at everything from my
intelligence to my sexual orientation in the midst of it all black.
Totally cool. As usual, asked if I was back on the team. Yes, Sergeant.
I replied. I am reporting for duty. I am a new one.
One I know more about the team,
the AAO and the bullshit in camp. Oh sorry.
You know more about the team, the AOE and the bullshit here in camp than I do.
I want, I want a black to understand.
I was willingly putting myself under his command and that my goal was not to
challenge him, but to learn from him.
A recon man who thinks he knows it all is a recon man headed for trouble.
And if I could capture those,
that attitude right there and distill it among every person that's moving into a
leadership position like this, the humility that you show here,
the willingness to subordinate your own ego is like the best sign of a great
leader. When you check into a situation, you go, Oh, you know what?
I don't know everything. And by the way,
if I think I know everything I'm wrong and oh there's someone that's been here
for a while, guess what? Cool. I got no problem working for you.
I'm here to support. I'm here to, I'm here to look out for the team.
I'm here to help the team win,
not here to look out for my own little agenda.
So that was awesome.
And that's been black. He's just an amazing man. And um,
so I totally respect him and was glad that it worked out.
Thanks to Billy Alexander or as your cut get over there pretty quick.
And I'm with Lynn, you know,
he had done a tour duty with the one 73rd, and his,
he lost a brother there and he still came back cause he wanted to get his fair
share of an NBA dead just to take some personal revenge.
And uh, you know,
we had that mission where he came up against a 10,000 and survived Mason's
mother one of our amazing heroes. And um, so yeah, I respected him and then uh,
later on we began, there's no sop and the sergeant major Hobbes,
he asked us to do an sop.
Yeah, that sounded like a,
that's something that we needed to start doing the seal teams to you.
There's another, here's another section in here where you start talking about,
well,
it appeared to me and we were actually talking about this before we started
recording and that's when you go to meet the new commander and here we go back
the book because I hadn't met the seat CN commander.
I Polish my jump boots to spit shine hoping they might make a positive
impression. When I met him later that afternoon, the call came down to meet him.
I put on the last pair of starched fatigues I had in my possession,
put on my new green baret and the spit shine to boots. So there you go.
You're getting squared away and again,
this is one of those things where you're in your second tour of Vietnam.
You know you're an SF guy, you've been in all kinds of really tough situations,
but you're going to meet the commander. Okay, cool. Be Humble, get squared away,
uniform on, try and make a good impression.
The commander of CCN made it a point to say that he ordered recon teams to break
contact with enemy forces and continue the mission.
I knew that several other recon teams had been unsuccessful in getting the
tanker. So this guy's a tanker. This guy was a tanker. He, I don't know.
What do you want?
You want to give us a little briefing on what that new commander was like?
Um, yeah,
he was assigned Nair and he was a friend of general crate neighbors who was the
overall commander. Abrams had seceded, Westmoreland [inaudible] as the, as the,
uh, top commanding officer for all of Vietnam as he was one of his buddies.
And so an order to build up his career, uh,
apron sent him to an NSF unit. So He'd get built up his metals, get to time.
And at that time in the army,
if you served as special forces for anything much longer than six months as an
officer, your career was done.
You would not get to promotion as the West pointers and the other guys that we
get your, your career was just finished.
But if you had a certain amount of time, and he came up there, uh,
which we learned later was to, uh, build his metal portfolio.
And we have some other stories that go on later on.
So he never really adjusted nor did he apparently understand SF and the way we
worked, particularly on a recon teams and whole thing about uh,
break contact and team mission while Sir if you're with me on the ground and you
want to say that, that's cool.
But if you're up there 5,000 feet and telling me to break contact a team
mission, what a six man recon team,
we got 10,000 guys wanted a party now but I will can't quite say it that way
till you go into extreme PC mode. Yeah.
And you were just meeting each other too. It's like I heard he was uh, uh,
he was lacking compared to his previous commander we had there.
Yeah. And the, the idea, you know,
I think its patent said the commander in the field is always right,
which is a great thing to lean towards from your perspective.
When you're up at 5,000 feet or back in Attack Gull operation center,
you kind of assume that your guy in the field is making the right call and try
and support them.
And there's so many times where I read the stories that you writers,
the stories of the other guys that you're writing about, the, the,
the difference between the teen being overrun and killed is a minute.
It's two minutes, sometimes it's seconds. You know, it's like these, uh,
of the time when you got,
when the fire as you're taking off the fire consumes the area we were just in.
That's followed by the NVA. So often these situations,
as soon as they started to go bad, even in the slightest way,
it's like okay we gotta we gotta start figuring out how we're gonna get outta
here. Cause if we try and fight by the time we make the decision.
So if you try to do this idea of his,
which is break contact and then continue the mission, I mean,
is it really possible for you to break? So you lose a bunch of your Ammo,
what do you figure a third year Emo,
half of your ammo and a quick gunfight and now you think the enemy's just gonna
walk away.
And the fundamental flaw here is this is a secret mission.
It's a clandestine operation. If you make contact with the enemy quote,
you've been compromised.
But somehow that didn't compute with the tanker [inaudible]
yeah. So you're in there, you're talking to them. And, and here we go.
Back to the book,
I knew that several other recon team had been unsuccessful in getting the tanker
to change his mind on that topic. So I approached it from a different angle.
I asked him to place himself in the one zero position in the field because most
of the ones,
euros I knew would do anything within their power to successfully complete a
mission if the tactical situation was conducive to it. But once compromised,
it was often militarily difficult to do.
So with a six man recon team against large numbers of NVA soldiers,
he promised me think more on the topic and I saluted and returned to the team
room, leery of the new CEO. So you did you even at an,
even at a young age,
you had the had the kind of understanding maybe I'm not going to approach things
head on, hey, you know, you're, you're not trying to store your dome.
That's a bad idea. No, it's like, hey, you know sir,
from my perspective as a one zeros, what we see it's a little bit different.
I just was impressed with the fact that you were playing the game a little bit
to try and build a relationship with this guy. Try and get him on your side.
Spider Parks and Pat Walker
does it have to be [inaudible].
We a couple offices here that are real dickheads in the beginning and when they
took over command of they would be making bad decisions and didn't understand a
situation but at least majority of the senior officers meaning a major or
lieutenant colonel, our case majority,
once they'd been there and saw what we were up against in the field.
It just took a while for that little time gap from when they land.
They want to prove their hard ass,
they want to be a good CEO now you got to worry about their career too and
between that reality and what we're dealing with on the ground and usually most
of them came around. This guy was not one of those that was a,
didn't have that capability.
You're just seeing it in his, his own perspective.
Yeah. I had learned from the pros, you know spider Pat Wok is John McGovern.
These were all senior SEOs and I watched them in situations dealing with
sergeant majors and S3 particularly on mission stuff before the mission and
afterwards how they would talk. And I picked up a lot of, I like the thick,
I absorbed some of their pcs skills cause I had none.
And the, and the,
what would you say the goal was from a leadership perspective as you're talking
to these guys? I mean I always say, look, if I've got a boss,
my goal is to try and form a relationship with me so that he listens to what I'm
saying. Cause if I go down there and bud heads out of the gate,
they're not going to listen to me. If I tell this boss this tanker, Hey,
you don't know what you're talking about. Wealth,
he's not going to listen to another word I say. But if I say, Hey Sir Roger,
that I want to give you some perspective on this that I've seen, you know,
whatever.
Just trying to talk to them with respectfully try to build a relationship.
That's what I try to do.
Yeah. And with the CEO.
He just tried to stay hell away from deal to sergeant major because they'd been
all been on the ground.
They had experience and they appreciate it what we were doing.
They knew what we're doing day by day. Our sergeant majors were squared away,
um, with exceptional one,
but most of the ones I dealt with and we're just really lucky.
So I tried to deal with them. Keep the COO site, stay away from is the best way.
Officer avoidance, sir. Officer avoidance. That's a good one. Uh,
moving forward a little bit in the late afternoon is black and I went over the
final mission preparations. Jenkins came running into our hoots with bad news.
R T Maryland has been hit.
Walton Brown or down Jesus h Christ, I can't believe it. Walled told me they,
that they told him it was a dry hole. Give me your PRC.
25 someone said they heard Brown on the radio.
As I screwed the long antenna into the PRC.
25 black ass Junkins any word on the bright light team?
He turned to me with a frown on his face. No word yet replied Jenkins,
but I want to go if there is one.
We all moved outside to get better radio reception on our FM radios.
The news got worse. Junkin said he could hear Covey talking to Brown.
All the Americans were down and being overrun. Junkin said,
have you heard Covey's last conversation with Brown when a wounded Brown told
Covey they were being overrun?
He said he heard the AK 47 firing.
Okay.
And then there was radio silence.
All communications with r t Maryland were lost.
The weather over the target closed in precluding any bright light missions for
10 days when a bright light finally went in.
Team members found only American web gear near the last loan location of our t,
Maryland. No further evidence of the team was ever located
walled Brown and Sergeant Donald Monroe shoe.
The newly appointed team member were listed as presumptive killed in action.
The loss of walled Brown and shoe was a reminder of just how deadly the AOT
continued to be in SOG. As always,
the recon men talk to each other afterward to see if there were any lessons to
be learned from their loss. Well, the weather was bad.
Sergeant Major John Hobbes suggested to black myself and a few others in recon
that perhaps a recon book should be written containing and documenting the
team's standard operating procedures.
Yeah,
so there you go. That's when you got started on that Damn Tacos. Yeah.
Lynn was a phenomenal,
he is a phenomenal artist and so he would do a lot of sketches and then we
worked on every sop from everything from just getting pre mission.
What would you, what you would carry a,
break it down between America's IA ditch batteries,
claymores five-second fuses and then adapting to the AOE you're going in.
Um, of years and layoffs. They had a lot of water,
so you only carry one t cantina water and purification pills.
Other times it was dry. You had to carry more water, which is more weight.
So always tried to stay low as possible.
And that as one of the fluctuation weight factors that we have some control
over. How much were you use the carrier?
At least 80 to 90 pounds back then. And we uh,
we [inaudible] was your body weight? Ah,
I think it was about one 70 soak and wet.
Maybe one 75 but the most after rnr
and you're carrying 80 pounds. 90 pounds. Yeah.
Cause I carried the radio plus the a 600 plus rounds for the car am sitting in
the iron rails in a frag grenades and you guys know it wore no body armor.
Oh No, no helmet. The body armor back then was this clunky stuff. Yeah.
And it was just, you know,
and the helmet was just made too much noise and his weight and in the jungle
would just get caught up and stuff. Whereas I just wear to cravat all the time.
And then the try to cover my blonde hair
again, this is a, you know,
every time I read one of your one at one of the stories that you write about,
you know, you made it out, you know, you, you,
you had that extra claymore that gave you enough time to get on the bird.
You laid down that extra fire, the, the, the,
the air ships showed up in time to put down cover fire and here with these guys,
with our t, Maryland, like those seconds didn't happen.
Those aircraft didn't show whatever the case may be.
And that's what was at stake every single time you guys went out there. Right?
And just like we said, and across the fence, all the Americans were killed.
Dee and digital left alive. So they were hit by,
we assume sappers and with the indigenous,
it's a psychological thing on all the troops in camp.
You had to deal with that again. But like with my team,
we just pulled the team together and said, hey, tell us what you heard.
We don't, we don't have a problem with you guys, but when this happens,
just be advised.
Keep Lynn and I appraised of anything you hear that could be negative or
troublesome, then we'll squelch it right away or deal with it.
In this case, did the indigent, the [inaudible] make it out for,
they never heard from again or no. Two out of three made it out. Uh,
one was killed as they came out of the forest,
there are near a marine compound of some sort.
And because they were in ditch when he came out arm,
the marine took him out and the other two were able to surround surrender and
make a gestures of some sort that they were able to get picked up,
came back and he took him down to Saigon for the full debrief and everything.
And did you guys ever get word on that debrief way late where they only thing we
heard was from Covey and cubby said that they had,
the team is set up for his rest over night spot too early and he thought it was
a dangerous spot but the one zero didn't listen to him. And uh,
so everybody was,
I'm surprised that we did it cause Walt had been one zero for a few months.
He had been in Marine Corps First, Cain,
SF and then he ran a few missions out of f will be one and half would be one
shutdown. Uh,
he came down to a fob for CCN.
What'd you guys always know who the Covey was?
Who the Covey rider was going to be?
No, no. Uh, sometimes it fluctuated, uh, particularly at the,
we went down to fob four cause the air force changed their pilots and all the
copywriters we had fob one got reassigned somewheres else.
So none of them carried on as copywriters. Now pat walkers came home,
he d roast out, spider parse came to CCM,
began another assignment and I saw a spider very little, uh, because I,
I couldn't even tell you what his assignment was. We just saw each other.
So little there. Cause Lynn and I are busy running
with the Covey rider. Do all the mission planning with you?
No. A Deli.
The cubby rotter and a pilot would be in for the final briefing at base or at
the launch site and it was just talk about LZs uh,
any anti aircraft because they continue to bring down more anti aircraft.
Everything from the uh, uh, 37,
Mike Mike's to the heavier anti-aircraft artillery that came in later.
Did that, did they ever get, did the coveys ever get shot at and shot down?
Always. We have several that went down and um,
there is a, what altitude would they fly at? Well,
um, they would do everything from way up high when they're just doing a general
recon to when a team would be on the ground,
they would have to spot the team either through smoke or mirror or from a
location you'd have, you'd be on a proud of point that they could pick us out.
Well, most of the times would be signal mirror that we'd flashy up to them.
They'd lock in on us that way. But once they got to doing actual coverage,
they would come down really low and [inaudible] stuff and there would be oh two
to slow movers. The little push pool. Yeah. Um, yeah,
we lost several coveys
it seems like those, I mean,
I can't imagine being the Covey rider in this one for our team, Maryland.
And you're, you're there and you're,
you're basically watching your guys get overrun. And I mean,
it isn't even after you maybe made suggestions that they moved somewhere else,
but you know, they don't see, but you're still supporting them. I mean,
what a helpless feeling.
That's gotta be rough at most of the Covey riders were guys that couldn't
operate for whatever reason.
No, they were, well they were former SF, so sometimes would be, um,
SF men had been in country for eight or nine months and then they would be
signed to Cubbyrise. So they had experienced on the ground,
there are short timers. So it was viewed as, as a,
a job that was not quite as dangerous as being on the ground,
but it had its own hidden dangers. Yeah, yeah. And, and
it seems like you would,
you would just want like someone that you really knew and trusted as your
copywriter. Right.
And so like in my case, we had a bunch of new ones,
so this cubby rider was great. Uh,
he just picked everybody up brand as well.
We had a couple others that we dealt with and some of these guys like Spider
Pars. Here's a couple of times when there's no error available. So you say,
well, how low did they get? They would make a gun run with a car.
15 spider would hang out the window. Foreigners car 15 at the NBA.
I don't even know what to say to that. Yeah. Yeah.
And he wasn't the only copywriter did that.
I mean other guys who dropped her mouth for an MCT nine,
that's what they tried to do to,
to give us support while we're waiting for the year air force in the other
aerostats to get there. You know, I was thought so when I went to see school,
you know, they, they taught us how to use signal with the mirror.
Then in my mind, cause I'm dumb,
I would think like I'm thinking like how well does it really gonna work?
I can't believe every, that's like your primary signal device? Absolutely.
Was the signal mirror? Yeah.
Every time that we had been on the ground for a period of time had to reconnect.
Everything was all signal through the mirror and we had to get the flash.
You get the copy on the right side so he could see us getting it, you know,
everything y'all. Yeah. How big is that mirror?
That was just a regular signal mirror. Like a, maybe a five by three.
Three by five? Yeah. Like a cell phone. Did you have?
I had this even though I didn't really believe in signal mirrors.
I guess I had this like special signal mirror that when you pointed it at the
thing it got like a little shade.
There's a little circle in the middle that got a little shade on it when you'd
be in the right spot. You know what I'm talking about? Yeah. Uh, I don't know.
I never figured out how that quite worked. Okay.
I just want to get the flashy up so they could see it.
Did you do like the technique where you're aiming at your hand and pointing at
the thing at the aircraft? No,
I would just make sure we had the flashy and just point it in general.
I didn't get that high level of training. And you had sir,
well thank God I didn't never have to do it cause I probably would have been
able to pull it off. Well triple camp is a little different than the desert.
Yeah. Yeah. And so in the triple canopy,
that had to be a challenge to find a hole in the jungle to get through with the
flash. In the first place.
Then you had to get the cubby lined up with your hole and then with the mirror
flash, you would, you would look at us nowadays and think we were,
we were weak with all the crap that we've got. We got laser pointers,
we got little signaling devices, transponders.
I know we can be your equipment. There's no question about that.
Not to mention you're not,
we would have run over both of our mothers for photos. No. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Oh yeah.
And you guys had some starlight scoped and you guys have some starlight thing.
There were big and heavy. We never carried it in field. No,
we only used them for a couple teams. Did A,
I couldn't even tell you which ones a, I'd never heard about it much,
at least with fob one or our time.
CCN But we use the frame bushes and there were so bright than you.
They ruined your night visits. So one be blown out for
them from the green sensors that they use to amplify the light.
And then your other eye was for night vision.
Hmm.
Okay. Awesome stuff. Uh, you after this,
after our t Maryland disappears, uh,
going back to the book next morning,
Hobbs asked me if I would courier a packet of sensitive information to Mack
resach headquarters in Saigon. You end up going to Saigon.
You ended up doing a little bit of Thailand is a time in Thailand as well cause
you got a little pass.
It sounds like you had a good time there of which you don't remember a lot.
True. Uh,
you get back to Saigon and you're waiting for a return flight to Denang.
You'd spent all your poker money, which remind me never to play poker with you.
And here we go back to look.
For some reason I couldn't fall asleep that night in Saigon.
I lay there on my bed looking at the ceiling, watching the ceiling turning,
still not believing that I had returned to Vietnam and to ASOG at some point.
I remember thinking when I was in nom, during my first tour of duty,
I dreamed of returning to the states. When I finally got home,
I found myself drawn back to nom.
Of course there were pressing legal matters at Fort Devons that can contributed
to my leaving the u s of a. As I lay there,
I found myself asking myself, what the hell are you doing here?
You could die. It's like realization.
Yes. Dentical scene from the apocalypse. Yeah, it is. It is. And Martin Sheen.
Yeah.
That mental tape replayed many times in my mind that night in many different
forms, but the essence of the issue was when I was in nom,
I wanted to go home. When I was home, I wanted to go to nom.
Once again, I thought of home where other than my family,
there was no compelling reason to return. I had no job waiting. I had no job,
no career to speak of.
I imagined going to one of those county employment centers and saying, hi,
I was a one zero and a secret war that I can't talk about. I can fire my car,
15 from the hip real good and I can hit a target at 400 meters with my f sawed
off m 79.
And I could bring napalm so close that it'll suck the air out of your lungs.
Thus, at the age of 23, I had my midlife crisis.
There was a, uh,
a picture that one of my platoon chiefs told me about.
He had this mentor Vietnam seal,
who was a mailman in imperial beach,
California [inaudible] and you know,
he had come home from Vietnam and become, you know, what am I going to do?
And he became a mailman. And he had, and Ma,
my platoon chief said that that guy had a on his wall and it was,
uh, it was, uh,
taken from the behind of a guy in fatigues with his web gear on and his weapon
slung and, and you're, and he's looking at a,
like a corporate guy in a desk and the corporate guys looking up at him and the
caption underneath it says, I'm sorry sir,
we don't have a job here for appointment. Exactly.
Which is sounds like how you were feeling. It's perfect on point. Yeah. Yeah.
And you're,
you got this and this is, you know, it's interesting,
I was just talking to one of my buddies, um,
and he was saying, look, you know, sometimes I hear people say, oh,
I loved being in combat and when they say that I kind of get pissed at them and
I think, you know, if you loved it so much or he's like, he says, I don't,
I didn't love it so much or you know, I had a hard time with, you know,
it was hard and I'll do, I would do it again if I had to,
but I'm not dreaming about it until we had this little conversation.
What I ended up saying to him was I said, well,
W when I was on my last deployment to Iraq and you know, there's,
you know, we had some guys wounded, we had some,
we had had had one guy killed at this point and there starts to be like,
you start seeing those negative feelings start to start to grow a little bit.
You know, guys start questioning stuff, guys start, hey, you know,
what are we doing this off? Hey, who, who's who, what?
Why are we doing this mission? And then you start to feel that,
and then guys start can be start to become negative.
And one of my platoon commanders came to me and said, you know, hey man,
you know, this is going to be rough when we get home. These guys are gonna be,
you know, W we, we might not, they're going to be mad about this.
They're gonna be mad about that. They're gonna be mad about something else.
And I said, let me tell you what's gonna happen. I said, when we get home,
when you talk to them three days after we get home,
they will have forgotten 10% of the bad stuff.
And in a week they'll forget 30% in, in a month,
they'll forget 50% I said, in a year,
the only thing they'll remember about this deployment is the fun,
cool stuff that's,
and that's kind of what I think makes guys like me say, man, I,
I had a, it was awesome. I would love to go back of course,
because we block out, you know, some of the hard memories. And for me,
I also always say the absolute best time of my life was being a tasking to
commander and the battle Ramadi.
And the worst time of my life was being a task unit commander and a battler
model. Cause there's nothing worse than losing your guys.
Oh and so it sounds like that was hitting you sort of mid deployment of hey
look, or when you were home, when you were back in America, you got,
you got money problems, you got girl problems, you got law problems,
you got what all those problems and they can all go away. Yes,
they can all become insignificant as soon as you get home that see one 30 and
fly back. And
I thought about Hep Sal [inaudible] a two one in the team.
I genuinely had that guilt feeling of them there and me not being there with
him. I felt as a, as a Greenbrae, I should've been there with him all along,
but we had a tour duty as you know. And, um,
so I was in a way, I was really glad to be back on the team. But yes,
a little bit more mature now and thinking a little bit, maybe two months,
but that night in that hotel and then 20 years later when apocalypse now comes
down, I go like, how the hell they get in my head for that scene.
You obviously, you, you, you get through that,
that apocalypse now scene
of staring at the ceiling and thinking, you know,
every minute that I'm in the Bush, every minute I'm in this hotel,
Charlie gets stronger cause he's out in the bush. You get back,
um, and you're on another mission. And I'm jumping into it right now.
As I snapped out of my snooze, you're asleep and helicopter.
I snapped out of my snooze.
I looked at out the starboard door just as we flew over the to start a layout,
Laotian farmers, a woman and two water buffalo,
the big chopper then hopped over the hedge row and landed in an adjacent field
as ingles. And I frantically awakened to the rest of our t, Idaho.
I was mad as hell. It wasn't bad enough.
They hadn't bothered to alert us as we approached the target area,
but now they were compounding that FOA. Paul,
by flying too close to indigenous farmers and then depositing us in the middle
of an open field,
far from our primary LZ and farther yet from the bridge.
That was the primary objective of our mission that this particular mission was a
pretty simple one, at least on paper,
which I take it with a serious grain of salt.
When you say admissions is a pretty simple one. Yeah.
By early 1970 the brass had become aware of something new and rather creative on
the part of the NVA underwater bridges.
These were being put in in place at strategic spots along the Hotel Minh trail
where it ran through Laos from the air.
It would appear as though the trails were interrupted by water in some places
several feet deep.
Yet it was apparent that the trucks heading south were crossing these streams
with ease. A closer review of aerial photographs, however,
had revealed that the ever inventive NVA had come up with an underwater
structure that could support heavy trucking.
While remaining virtually unobservable from the air.
It was a devilishly clever idea and well executed to boot. So that's a pretty,
they just built these like, they're like maybe like six inches underwater.
The bridge.
Yeah. And we looked at the pictures. You couldn't tell, uh,
they really done it well. And um, so that was the mission is simple.
Go in and find out what they are, take pictures and blown the hell up.
Simple mission. Yeah. If it'd be more fun to blow them up with the truck.
Okay. And
you were, you guys were sleeping, the helicopters hadn't there.
No one woke you up. And the reason why we lost from Thailand,
the weather had been socked in in Vietnam, so it was a bad weather spelled,
which was February of 1970 and they flew us by, um, blackbirds,
which were the, uh, uh, clandestine service.
Air Lift for us flew to Thailand. We land in Thailand,
which is neutral at the air force base. And the black truck comes up, we get in,
has curtains, they can't see us. We go back to the base.
And my old commander from fob one was the CEO at that launch site,
which was the 46 special forces group.
And they were there just to be in country, but they had decided to seek a war.
Spazz came out of there to have cubbies out of there.
And so we launched and the air force had the HH threes,
the bigger helicopters, like the jolly green giant,
but a scaled down version without the armor plating.
So we launched from there and we flew for two or three hours cause the long
flight from Thailand across a western layoffs.
And we launched the,
as we landed at a fuel dump in the middle of last,
yeah, it was run body agency. Oh, okay. So we land Ewald yes, we refill.
But you get off, you go like, hey man, who are you? He goes, I'm not here. I go,
welcome my here. Either he says have a good day while you're not here.
And we continue to go in. And then the air force put us down in that,
that canyon.
And that's one thing that's always interesting when you're using helicopters.
The helicopter, when you're supposed to insert at one spot for them,
they, they, they miss that spot by a minute or whatever.
For them it's no big deal. Like, Hey,
they just flew them in a little bit long for you on the ground,
that minute is a long time. I mean that can be a kilometer.
It could be like a really massive amount of space that you just missed. Oh yeah.
And this is like the dip between the valley and the Pete.
We want to go in on so we could run at night a little bit cause there's some
open areas that we could cover and didn't get down maybe at the middle of the
night to check this thing out in the morning at first light.
That's where our plan was. Just didn't happen. We're in a valley and it's like,
uh, okay. We flown out here. I certainly don't want to just fly back.
Pissed everybody off. Let's give it a shot. We're here,
we're on the ground scope. So we had to get up, put our gear on first.
We didn't even have a routine insert where everybody goes out on full alert and
we can get out and put the damn equipment on. And then we're like, okay,
we're in a valley in the mountain,
we want to be on several thousand feet above us and we're in this valley.
Are you carrying a regular topographic map?
Is that your primary means of navigation? Yes,
and they would have the big map and then our target where we plan to go,
they would cut a 10 by 10 cut it out. And that's also all we carried.
So if we got caught there be nothing else besides just that,
that grid that we were in. And did you ever use any imagery as well to,
to no compliment that. Nope.
Strictly map the Covey pile if they did a VR visual reconnaissance prior to the
mission. But here it wasn't. We, uh,
the cubby had told them here's the target area and for some reason the air force
has went down through the valley and dropped us there.
All right. Continuing on,
given the rather undistinguished nature of our arrival or sorry,
undisguised nature of our arrival.
We knew it was only a matter of time before hundreds of NVA troops,
trackers and dogs would be pouring down on us on that road looking for us.
So you want s w cause we get to work with dogs.
So like I can't imagine knowing going in that I'm going to be facing dogs that
are going, coming after us.
And obviously you guys work cause you guys carried mason pepper and all this
other stuff to throw them off. But what a nightmare that is.
I still hate dogs. My wife loves him but, and the kids love them.
Do you have any dogs? Yeah, we got a fleabag running around the house.
His name is gunny buddy ways. It's like we got him from other, from a gunny.
So okay. Um,
ours was no tourists, John. Furthermore,
it's very unsettling to be moving through this beautiful valley in broad
daylight at what? For a recon team passed at breakneck speed.
It was not a comfortable way to proceed. We took no breaks,
not wanting to spend a moment longer than necessary in such an exposed position.
So you're just hauling ass. Oh yeah.
Trying to get out of this valley as fast as you can
and you end up going up a hill, a big hill.
And we split the team too for awhile.
I put the angles on one side of the valley and me on the other,
it wasn't that big in terms of width. Been wide enough to, I could see him,
he could see me. Okay. Just a warmth divide.
And then the detailed gunners took care of our foot footprints.
And what was your reason for that call? Um,
I just wanted to split the team up to see what was on the other side of the
valley. We couldn't tell either side what was there. So I figured we could,
if there's any enemy,
we wanted to find out on both sides at once and try to get to a point where we
could begin to find a spot to get up. The mountain could be,
are gonna run out of daylight. Got It. So it was a little bit of a, of a, of a
panic, not panic move. It was a, it was, hey, we're no Tufts situation.
One of the best ways we can get out of this is we put teams on both sides of
valley. We're looking for a way to get into the top of this thing.
I knew you talk about this earlier now.
I used to warn guys all the time about splitting forces.
Oh yeah. And it's like really risky. Really,
really risk is one rule you never do. And I've, I did it twice. Okay.
So I just wanted to confirm that. Oh yeah, no, absolutely. And the,
the situation was such that we couldn't tell what was on either side.
So I figured we're going to have a firefight.
At least now there'll be minimal forces.
Our four w we went in an eight man team at times had four and four,
four and four and John had been on the ground with me previously, so I
wasn't worried about John and a soap.
We're going to have a firefighters do with minimal forces.
We could survive and then get the prairie fire and worry about getting Outta
here. Otherwise proceed.
B And d covers much ground because of that mission where we set up the ambush.
We had,
we had great success by not stopping because the NVA knew that we would go 10
stop 10 so they would anticipate how far we traveled here.
It's like we covered maximum ground hauling ass. Yeah.
All right. Now you end up finding a place to go up this hill and here we go.
Back to the book. By now we were out of breath.
The grueling climb with all our combat gear was starting to wear on us,
and each additional steps seem to bring an increased in the steepness of the
incline.
It was growing painfully clear that those periodic volleyball games we had
played back at camp weren't sufficient physical training.
Did you? What'd you guys, what'd you guys do for PT back then? Not enough
volleyball gets off. That was it. Yeah, because we were so busy, you know,
between the mission, mission prep, and then he started sticking us in isolation.
I was going to ask you that. Would you,
would you be tired when you're going into the field or would you be well rested?
Cause like on this one, he fell asleep. You guys were all asleep. Oh yeah.
I'm gonna tell you right now, like when we would go in the field,
most of the time when I would go in the field, especially in Ramadi,
I would be exhausted by the time I went in the field because we'd spent all this
time planning and de conflicting and briefing and doing all this stuff.
By the time I went in the field, it was like the time for me to go, okay,
hey someone, someone's saying watch,
I'm going to sleep for an hour or two hours. You know, that happened a lot.
Yeah. We usually had a nights rest prior. Yeah. It's nice. Yeah, it's a luxury.
Very nice. Um, going back to the book, however,
any thoughts of letting personal pain slow us down or not so subtly overwritten
by noise noises we could hear from the north of us.
The menacing sounds made us forget our dry throats keeping lungs,
pain needs and knees and aching backs. The enemy was out there and the game,
as they say, was on the forces. Might not yet be joined,
but the fight was in the offing, so he knew it was coming.
And then you guys go into like a series.
The Sao leads you guys into like a serious fight of vines,
thorns undergrowth.
We went in and then we went in deeper and then he pushed us the third time and I
was pissed because I tore my fatigues. I'm going, sal, you know,
de Dinky Dow like you're crazy. You're pushing it. He was right. I was wrong.
We went into third level. Yeah, and then you get in so deep.
Eventually settled down and tried to get as comfortable as possible on a 40
degree slope,
around 2100 we heard numerous trucks on the main road in just a few minutes.
Several had driven slowly past our remain overnight position.
Unfortunately,
the happy times were spoiled when we soon heard the barking of tracking dogs
around zero 100 we heard the enemy troops move north on the road.
While on the east side, someone opened fire with a few AK 47 bursts.
The distinctive bark of the Russian made weapon jarred us into full alert.
How long could they keep it up in which direction would they move?
We sat in the inky darkness, a darkness so complete.
I couldn't see my hand in front of my face.
It sounded as though they were making their way north.
That's how dark it is and you have no night vision.
It's just pitch black. Again,
it didn't take long before we had enemy troops on both sides of us.
As dense as our cover was,
we could see the flickering light from the lamps the NVA carried as the enemy.
Soldiers began probing the bottom tip of the finger.
We were on vehicle activity on the road picked up noticeably.
This gave us a very uneasy feeling, had sound not driven us on the NVA,
might well have spotted us, but as it was, we were a sconce too,
so deep in that godawful thicket that w that the one enemy soldier who
approached our position hesitated and then gave up defeated by the phony
vegetation.
We could almost feel him thinking better of it and deciding to return to his
comrades.
Little did he appreciate how close to death he'd come with five car fifteens and
an m 79 aimed in his direction.
Slowly the NVA troops tired of their frustrating and uncomfortable search and
called it off our t, Idaho could finally release the collective breath.
It had been holding.
The danger was not gone not by a long shot but just briefly retired from the
field of play,
so thank God you were deep in that Bush. Oh yeah.
And you know like I forgave sale
cause it's like this is,
we don't need to go that far as I could look on my fatigues. I'm bleeding here.
He's right. The Sal was always right. I always listened to him.
So the night goes by at firstlight our options were severely limited.
We couldn't move north, south or east, which left us one choice,
not wanting to spend another day and night tied to trees on the side of a hill.
We opted for the obvious and moved out in a Western lead direction for the rest
of the day. We climbed the side of the steep mountain.
Did you guys ever move at night or do you guys try pretty much to remain in one
position at night? Try to stay in one position,
particularly in a triple canopy because just too much noise in Cambodia.
When we're on flat territory, we could've moved and we'd thought about it.
[inaudible] but uh, uh, no, not in Laos.
Several times the rock face was so steep.
We had to tie together six foot strands of rope we used for Swiss seats to make
rope long enough to advance up to the next level of rocks.
So we're talking serious terrain. Oh, horrible.
Just as last light was feeding in a darkness,
we reached the top of the mountain. I was physically beat.
My pants were torn in my hands, knees and legs were covered with cuts,
scrapes and bruises. We were a mess.
We set up our ROI plan quickly and took turns eating rations before settling
into the nightwatch rotations. After the previous night nights, Ron,
this mountain tight mountain top site was paradise.
We could see enemy trucks moving south, but did nothing about it.
We were almost too tired to think extremely dangerous condition to be in wet on
the ground. Rast was what we needed, not confrontation.
You guys are exhausted, beat
and we, when we climbed, we did take our web gear off rucksacks Oh really?
We tied all the squishies together because we're going straight up.
So one guy would go up and then you shipped up the backpack,
then the web gear, put it back on, go to the next level.
We had to take that spread the shock it several times and just to get up cause
it was so steep but it was covered with enough vegetation.
They couldn't see us in the valley so they weren't quite sure where we were.
And we had put out the,
the mason stuff and other locations was fouled some of the dogs noses.
So it an all day climb and uh,
with only a couple when we broke for lunch and whatever. But yeah,
that was a nasty, nasty climb.
Okay.
When morning came we are woke to a beautiful sunrise and found that we are top
an unbelievably gorgeous Laotian mountain range.
The next few hours were the most spectacular ones I ever had spent on the ground
in any AAO. Moving north are wrong. The Ridge line.
We began gradually descending off and encouraging.
One beautiful new encountering one beautiful new vista after another.
Okay.
Around 12 or a hundred we found an area overrun with thousands of wild orchids
in full spectacular bloom back home.
Each plant would be worth five to $50.
We decided to take a break in the field and soon everyone with the exception of
sal was in the middle of them and acting like a delighted child,
picking the flowers and sticking them in their hair teeth and behind their ears
or in the buttonholes of their fatigues.
It was like a spontaneous outburst of happiness and while it was somewhat
foolish, it was also refreshing. I think we all felt better for it.
You just take any pictures and know, Oh man, I'm just going to see those. Yeah.
Oh yeah. You had the camera for the underwater bridge.
He didn't get the orchids, but sal was all business. Oh,
always. He's [inaudible] come on. What'd they go?
What was your nickname? Did they call you tilt as well?
No, these, he called me my, because the Vietnamese couldn't handle ours.
So instead admire was my,
got it. I could see him looking at you thinking my,
what are you doing with that damn flower of your hair?
Their phrase was Buku dinky doubt. Very, very stupid. Very stupid. Very crazy.
Yeah. How good. How good did your, did your Vietnamese get it sucked.
I had had [inaudible] and that was why we didn't have language training because
they knew that with SF, uh, put four years,
like for 64 to 68 were interpreters in place [inaudible] and then we just locked
out what happened. It was his best one.
He spoke good English and he cracked in my English and he spoke French.
Um,
was his background that he had all that good language skill. His Dad,
his son in school in Paris, so he has some education in France.
They spoke four languages and now he's an interpreter. Nom.
Yeah, Bro.
Going back to the book, we,
we came to a narrow strip of land that headed down from the hill.
I singled ingles and chow to set out to scout ahead while the rest of us
remained in place. Chow was 16 years old.
[inaudible]
he'd been on the team nearly two years.
So these kids had been on the team since he was 14 years old.
Yeah. When the team got wiped out,
chow cow and sewn were the three that we'd hired and brought on and we let a
couple others go.
He'd been on the team nearly two years ever since.
Spider parks would help rebuild the team in 68 Charles sensitive ears heard the
NVA moving up the mountain.
He warned ingles with hand signals and the two of them abruptly stop moving with
the enemy less than 10 meters away.
Yeah.
Ingles quietly broke sky squelch on his URC 10 emergency radio several times.
Alerting me to the danger.
Okay.
The rest of us were about 50 meters away.
The shit was about to hit the fan because we were so far removed from all their
support. There was no time to waste. None at all. We needed to jump on.
We need all the jump we could get on things.
So I quickly contacted a nearby O v 10 Bronco and declared a prairie fire
emergency setting in motion the string of responses that could save our lives
and get us out.
Does everybody, did everyone know, is that like a pro word?
Prairie fire emergency? Did everyone know exactly what that meant?
Tack Air at noon.
Right. And uh, then we also had the airborne command control,
but they weren't always over our a m they couldn't pick up the Fox Mike FMP.
[inaudible] so in this case we lucked out, um, that uh, ob 10 was,
I think there were one of the ravens who had,
they were surprise supporting another CIA operation that was further west until
they asked. And he had been up her to call and came over.
That was the first time he worked with ob tens man,
Lucky Barry.
While I was talking to the pilot, Charles Sao and ingles spring,
a hastily arranged ambush that [inaudible] on the startled enemy troops when
their appointment was less than a meter away.
Chao hit him with a full automatic burst from his car, 15 blowing and backward
Charles sound angles. Then hit the remaining enemy,
soldiers so hard and fast that they didn't have time to fire a single return
shot.
Ingles threw down a hand grenade down the hill to discourage anyone who might be
around. So this is all something that's happening. God,
a meter away there. He's really close, man. He came up the hill,
he was white because that was the first really real firefight the child had been
in and uh,
cause he be trained up and like he had the earnest [inaudible] team.
So this was his mission and that was,
he was down in with John and he was the head of John.
As the fight began to unfold, I took stock of the situation.
There weren't too many places for us to go.
Within minutes of the Bronco's arrival, the piloted spotted us.
He said he could see more enemy activity north of us along the hill angles and
sal were on.
He made a run on the enemy concentrations firing his rockets into their
position. Then he said somewhat laconically,
I've got two bits of bad news for you. First nom is socked in.
No assets can launch from there to extract you, which means Thailand assets,
which means at least three hours before the birds arrive on station.
Second to yourself,
there are approximately a dozen troops about 800 meters out and moving towards
you. I think you better sit tight until we get some help.
Okay.
By 1430 a Covey aircraft replaced the Bronco and repeated this sit tight
suggestion.
He agreed the eastern Western face of the mountain were too steep to descend.
He also confirmed the NVA were coming at us from the south and north.
They were clearly visible as they moved cautiously through the sparse veggie
vegetation. For the next half hour,
the enemy troops tried to locate us to discourage them. I directed several
[inaudible] [inaudible] Skyraider gun runs south of our position,
so this is another one of these things where I gotta like when you get,
you got the NVA move into your position and you get told, hey,
the closest extractor,
earliest we're going to be able to get you out of here is three hours from now.
Yeah.
We were up on an area where there is minimal escape routes or the jungle because
everything was so steep on several different size of that little,
we're like a little bit of a plateaued or had been like a trail that came down
and then John and Chao had gone down further,
another little finger and that's what it had to firefight. He came back up,
we put a perimeter out and luckily we may radio contact right away. So,
um,
Dov 10 went in with his rockets just to say it was 2.75 and then that's when he
gave us the good news. Yeah.
Good news that it's gonna be three hours at a minimum before they can get you
help. Yeah. That's why we carried a lot of bullets. Yeah.
That's a lot of that. It could be a long day.
I don't know if you can carry enough bullets for three hour firefight.
That's a nightmare. Uh,
back to the book of 12.7 millimeter enemy gun in the valley opened up on the
eight one. Ease.
I was sitting on the east side looking down at the valley floor after making
another gun run that a [inaudible] pilot told me he was pissed because the enemy
gunner was coming too close to him and his wing man. He wanted to nail him asap.
I gave the pilot where I fought was clear what I thought were clear verbal
directions to where the enemy Gunnar was located, but he couldn't find them,
so I told him simply to watch the ground for my and follow my tracers. At that.
I fired a short burst toward a clump of trees in the valley that were maybe 500
meters away. The pilot had no trouble seeing where my tracers hit.
Thanks partner.
He said in the low southern draw and then rolled in for the kill.
It was the most beautiful napalm dive I've ever seen.
The pilot came out of the sky pointing straight down his engine screaming.
It reminded me of dive bombers I'd seen on the television series of victory at
sea.
I really thought I was watching a World War II movie because I was so high up in
the mountain.
I was looking down on the Skyraider when at the absolute last second,
he released a napalm canister and pulled out of his gutsy dive.
It was a perfect strike. The impact generated a secondary explosion,
which was probably the gunner spare amo going off around him.
Black oily smoke billowed up.
There was not a whisper of sound from the former gun in placement for the next
three hours,
I directed air strike after air strike around our position and in the valley
at 1730 hours.
We heard the very welcome sound of the hh threes coming our way.
[inaudible]
as they approached in the distance,
the NVA pushed up from the north and hit Sal's claymore further south of us.
Another machine gun opened up from the valley.
As I gave Covey the compass heading to its position,
I caught sight of an enemy soldier climbing a tree about a hundred meters away.
Okay.
He had handed his RPG launcher to a nearby comrade while he'd gotten to that
position, it was clear he was looking for Archie,
Idaho or hoping to nail an air force chopper.
I was too far away to shout and alert to the other team members.
For the first time. In my 16 months of running missions,
I extended the collapsible stock of my car.
15 normally it remained compressed to minimize the length of the weapon,
but now I wanted it extended to help stabilize my aim.
Once I was ready, I carefully put the NVA soldier in my gun site.
Yeah.
In that fleeting moment, I felt like God,
I had the power of life and death concentrated in my fingertip.
As I grounded my elbow to steady my arm,
I found myself silently hoping the NVA troop would be unable to find the team
and simply climb back down the tree.
He didn't see either me or my car. 15 in a troubling way,
it seemed unfair or unsportsmanlike,
but war is not designed to be a sporting contest.
If the situation were reversed, I had little doubt what he would opt to do.
Although these reflections took less than a moment to form,
they caused deep soul searching on my part.
Okay.
I found myself recalling my third grade Sunday school teacher,
Mrs Myrtle right shirt and her treatment of the 10 commandments,
especially the one that proclaims thou shalt not kill Hell.
If I had met this treed soldier on the streets of Hanoi without guns and beyond
the rhetoric of politicians,
we'd probably be able to find lots of common ground between us and dozens of
purely human things to talk about.
Okay,
but that could not be. Not now, not at this given moment.
Also in my mind was the knowledge he would receive a metal if he ever managed to
kill me or one of my team members.
As I watched and reflected his comrade,
reached up and handed him a little rocket launcher,
I could tell it was unloaded what I had,
what I had come to think of my personnel,
my personal NVA moved a little farther up the tree craning his neck to find us
from the corner of my eye. I could see sun moved towards sal,
and at that very moment someone passed up around for the RPG.
I still refused to yield to the inevitable.
I continued to hold onto the stubborn hope that he would abandon his cause,
climbed down the damn tree and walk away. Instead,
he fitted the round into the end of the w, the launcher. I still watched still,
I waited even after he'd put the weapon to his shoulder as he nestled his neck
against it and began to take careful aim toward us.
I leveled my sight on his head.
I pulled the trigger a single yet timeless shot.
He dropped from the tree out of sight,
but not out of my mind.
One of those moments.
How far was he away?
When was the range? Well over maybe a foot football field and a half,
two fields. Cause like on the cusp of this,
of the hill and he was around on the side. Nick is here,
there was like a tree he climbed up that was above the regular vegetation.
So I'm not sure how high he went,
but I could see him the beginning and then just waited.
Yeah.
Cause uh, and then when he got that damn RPG [inaudible] yeah.
Then it's time to do what you gotta do. Oh yeah.
Okay.
And once again, I'm going to make this claim. I'm not reading this whole book.
I'm just jumping around and you should read this whole book if you're listening
to this because I'm getting 10% of what's going on in here.
Uh, this part continues on. Seconds later,
one of the approaching hh three pilots broke.
Okay.
Broke into my reverie by commenting somewhat frantically on the heavy ground
fire. He was taken from the mountains south of our position.
There was a moment's hesitation before he sadly announced,
I think we have some mechanical problems. We are going home.
We could see the helicopters, and they looked fine to us.
They were less than two kilometers out.
When they turned and disappeared into the fading Sun.
Our morale sank as they vanished after cursing our lack of, uh,
after cursing our lack of look and the pilot, I told the team to take a nap.
It going to be a long night. So there goes your ride out.
You've already been there for freaking ever. And you see those guys, Hey,
we got some mechanical problems. We're out of here. Yeah,
it was a very unhappy moment.
Uh, so you guys, uh, you tell the guys to take a nap. You take a little nap.
Yeah. And back to the book around 1930 ingles roused me. Wake up.
You're not going to believe this shit. As I came around,
he was pointing south up the mountain side from about 30 meters from our
perimeter. And as far as we could see,
there were dozens and dozens of lanterns bouncing and swinging along.
Each lantern was carried by an enemy soldier.
In between each lantern were many more soldiers.
The same scene was on folding to the north of us.
The NVA were coming up the hill on mass.
We could see at least a dozen trucks unloading hundreds of NVA troops in the
valley. Also across the valley and up on the plateau to the east.
There were hundreds of lights moving everywhere, like swarming, fireflies,
flitting around in the night in a smaller valley west of us still more lights,
more and VA, more trouble, just more,
more and more of everything we did not want to see.
I felt the tremendous weight of just how small Arty Idaho was.
How terribly isolated and alone we were,
how incredibly vulnerable.
All of a sudden I found myself praying for reasons only.
He understands.
My prayer was answered as a few minutes later.
The first specter,
c one 30 gunship arrived on target with its two 20 millimeter cannons and four
7.62 millimeter mini guns ready for action.
That had to be the most horrifying thing that you could ever think of.
You wake up and you see these enemy lights surrounding you,
hundreds of them, and you know that they're looking. Those hundreds,
maybe thousands of enemy personnel are looking for you and your six man team.
Oh yeah, they're coming for us. And it was just like, yeah, I'll be,
I'll never forget when John woke me up. I mean,
it was just one of those moments he just like, oh my God, fuck
me to tears and help me, Lord.
Yeah, please wake up. You're not the mom.
Keep it right about now if you're not praying, I'm back in New Jersey.
Please start praying now and then what? What? Do you have any idea?
Did you ever find out what were the,
see one 30 came from where the spectrum came from,
had that'd be all Thailand. And so it just randomly showed up.
I'll know that somebody was the Covey that we had talked to earlier who brought
the helicopters out, uh,
because the cub was still trying to work with us for other era assets.
And when it got dark we lost everything conventional. So all the a ones, fans,
phantom jets, um,
gone and they didn't have helicopter gunships out of Thailand,
just transport vehicle aircraft.
So we had that quiet spell and um,
so they had notified Spector and they had told me that they're going to try and
get a specter out. And uh, had you worked with the spectrum before? Uh, yes,
we used before. Um, but nothing like this night.
So for anyone that does know to a c one 30 specter gunship is, it's a,
it's a c one 30, which is like a big transport aircraft,
but they put some big weapon tree, in this case, two 20 millimeter cannons.
And for 7.62 mini guns,
which fire 6,000 rounds a minute. Correct. Something crazy. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like a,
it looks like a laser beam when the tracers come out of these things,
dog piss it from the sky or that
and uh, so these guys show up and here we go. Back to the book.
This was this awesome.
A wave array of weaponry could be made to form a magic link with my emergency
strobe light. Once that link was established,
the gunner could dance the incredible fire power of his four mini guns,
which is 24,000 rounds per minute total within five feet of us.
It was wondrous. It was miraculous.
It could save us on this particular night. However,
we were faced with a highly unusual, if not unique problem.
The pilot circling over US reported he couldn't pick out the teens strobe light
because there were so many other lights surrounding us.
The myriad of lanterns must have made the dark earth look like a pin cushion
illuminated from within. No problem. I said, I'll turn off mine.
You get the rest. Hit the ridge line west of the valley.
Give me a minute to put my team on the safe side of the mountain.
The Specter commenced to putting on an amazing display of fire power.
Once again, we gave thanks for being on the right side of the fight,
the one that had uncle Sam's air force and Spector on its team.
After ripping up scores of body and carving out large patches of empty darkness
on the Ridge Line, the specter directed his deadly fire into the valley.
More lanterns were snuffed out and the darkness spread like a stain as lights
and lives were extinguished.
The Specter crew finally expended all of its ordinance and the pilot apologized
for running out of ammo. The next specter arrived seconds later,
so they, they were just, they knew you were in a bad way and they were coming.
Oh yeah.
We were so happy that the second one showed up because now the lights are out so
we can turn the strobe light on and had direct Camo.
Did they have night vision back then in the specters? Oh yeah. Okay.
At everything. See your force. Yeah. Yes, it is.
Yeah. I mean,
there's the specter gunship is just the most awesome asset to have overhead for
ground support cause the capability, the visual capability that it has,
and then the accuracy of fire. And this is 1970. Think how accurate that was.
Oh, what they can do now. Oh yeah, yeah. Um,
the next specter arrived seconds later,
he quickly locked onto our strobe and worked the southern slope with a
vengeance. Marching his guns right up to the trail,
right up the trail to the top of the ridge beyond our line of sight. He worked.
Then he worked at Valley and the Southeastern Mountain Ridge.
A third specter arrived and worked our southern perimeter again,
systematically walking. It's fiery, led up the mountain around us.
There was no longer any light above us. No Moon, no stars.
The only sound was the roar of the sea.
One 30 overhead in the absolute darkness.
He could not be seen until his guns opened up.
Then tongues of fire seem to erupt out of nowhere,
like spontaneously generated bolts of lightning and the outlines of specters
fuselage would appear in brief flashes as a pale and ghostly silhouette and
airborne grim reaper.
When spectrum moved to other targets,
we could hear the enemy dragging away his dead.
At zero zero 45 Sao said some NVA were in the grass about 20 meters south of us.
A few minutes later he blew the claymores. We all instinctively flinched.
For some reason,
claymores always sounded more thunderous at night and caught you by surprise.
After the dust settled, we again heard NVA troops dragging away their bodies.
They never spoke. We heard no cries of pain.
They're silent.
Execution of grim duty was at once Erie and admirable Jesus.
They were tough. They fought hard and died hard.
So you wouldn't even, you'd hear these guys getting wounded,
getting blown up and they wouldn't even scream. They wouldn't cry.
It was just silence. It was amazing. Tuesday,
it's mind boggling.
Think that all those guys who were or just dead Kinda dead. We know,
but there had to be some wounded and of course not a sound,
but you hear them dragging the bodies.
Yeah.
I don't know how many we killed that night.
Go back to the book. Shortly before the next specter arrived,
I moved my team away from the edge of the slope and into the high grasses Sao
placed one more claim, more down on the northern slope. In short order,
specter locked onto our strobe light.
He reported that cloud cover was beginning to roll in the EO.
When spectre dropped,
when spectra then dropped illumination flares over a sow's eyes turned as big as
pizza tins, NVA troops within five meters of us,
all of about 15 feet blinded by intense white light.
They could not immediately make us out as we nestled into the high grass,
but this was a little real constellation. They would spot us soon enough,
I whispered into the radio asking Spector just how close he could bring the
ordinance to my strobe light as close as you want it.
Okay.
He first replied, I want it five feet in front of my southern perimeter.
I responded, well, he hesitated.
I can't bring it in any closer than 25 meters from your perimeter.
Unless you're willing to accept responsibility for any casualties,
we may accidentally inflict. We have to record you saying it.
Okay,
I wanted to scream. You dumb fucking idiot.
They're five meters away and you're going to quote in your quoting regulations
to me. Just kill the fuckers before they kill us instead.
And feeling like a complete fool.
I whispered that I was fully willing to accept responsibility for any and all
casualties that may or may not result from his efforts to save our lives.
I followed up by saying now bringing it in as tight as you can to the light.
I'm holding it up now move south from my light. I'll take my chances with you.
The gun crew finally opened. Fire in there in the fuselage,
cracked over our heads.
The ground in front of us are corrupted as thousands of rounds ripped into it.
Kicking up stones and dirt and tossing NVA soldiers around Mike Rag Dolls again.
Spector solely marched his stuff southward from our strobe light moving up the
ridge.
[inaudible]
danger close. Oh yeah,
so the flare goes off and south sees that the enemy are five meters from where
you're at. Yeah. I didn't realize they were that close.
They would are quiet. I mean they kept coming all night
and because it was pitch black and they were just so quiet and they just
probably moved during the wind or move during when rounds were hitting or
whatever, and they made it tough within five meters.
I mean that's when you're making this radio call. It's a miracle.
They couldn't hear you. They just didn't start shooting
towards your direction when you make the radio call.
That's why I was waiting for,
I was waiting for that next AK to open up on my voice.
Especially when they're asking you for the, Oh yeah. Oh,
you talk about moments.
That's insane. Totally. I wonder what the, I mean that's,
I'm actually surprised that they could pull off five meters. It was just for a,
anyone that's listening that doesn't understand this, this aircraft,
I don't know what, what altitude where they at? Do you have any idea?
They had to be at least two to 3000 feet above us. So,
and I don't know what the height of the mountain range or that, um,
a little plateau that we were on there, but several thousand feet above us,
they locked in that and, and put rounds within five meters of you. Oh yeah.
Yeah. I mean,
I could see they'd do it now because now they've got computers and they've got
all these, I mean, just incredible systems up there. I mean,
I've been in the modern AC one 30. They're ridiculous. Oh, is that right?
You've been at a, yeah. Yeah. They're crazy. Like they're, they're the, the,
the capability that they have is just completely ridiculous, but I can't, no, I,
I mean, I know there's no way they had that same technology back in 1970.
It just impossible. You know, there's more technology in,
in my phone than is in 1970 bird.
Those air force guys were good. And, uh, you know, we just kept a strobe light,
right pointed at the aircraft. So when it circled the, uh,
whoever had the m city, not, I did it for a while, then we'd take turns with it.
But we always followed the aircraft so it would be directly linked into that
stove line. That's right. Cause you had your, you put the strobe into the m 79,
right? Yeah. So it was only directional. Right. So we go straight up. Yeah.
So anybody on the ground wouldn't see it.
Hmm.
So that's what's happening as these guys are five meters from you. Oh yeah.
This is ridiculous. That's why I thought that night also
send me a King Bee, please. Yeah.
Um,
back to the book between Bursa fire, he dropped more flares this time.
The illumination revealed no movement south of us.
Instead Chow gleefully reported that there were Boku dead VC,
but the south quiet specter started on the northern flank and marched,
fired down the finger of land.
When I reported hearing more trucks in the valley,
that gun crews pounded them into silence and another specter circled us and laid
down its deadly ring of fire again,
bring it to within five feet of our strobe light.
Somewhere around zero 400 summer,
early morning fog and haze moved in as the last specter moved out.
Okay.
Once the spectrum was gone, the NVA started moving toward us once
more from the south. Only this time with real vengeance.
Okay.
Spectra spectrum killed a lot of their comrades and they were in no mood to back
off. But we managed to hold them off by employing what we called our guests,
whether I'm throwing a grey NAIT or not tactic,
which had a way of making almost an enemy almost any enemy. Think twice.
What was that all about? I didn't cover it in the book, but you wrote about it,
but what?
Well, it's another version of hide and go seek with a, uh, could,
we only had a limited amount of grenades. We used some already.
And so we knew that when we threw the grenade,
when the land that you would hear them run, that you would hear.
So we knew we were getting low.
So sal went out and got stones and Chow and that had the team went out and got
stone. Somehow they came back.
So we'd wait until he would tell us,
cause somehow he shall could just tell where they were. I could,
I didn't have that kind of definitive skill set. So he, uh, his signal,
he would let us know or he would just throw the rock. He told a rock,
you hear him scurry away like rats could.
They thought the [inaudible] was coming, so we throw another rock,
so it'd be less scurrying. So then we wait and throw another rock.
It'd be less scurrying than we throw it, another hand grenade.
So in that, this went on for quite a while, you know,
we always carried at least 10 hand-grenades I always carry these 10 or ditch
hatchery 10 yourself. Oh yeah, sure.
I had a cup on a strap and always in the rucksack.
And here's why. Just for that mission. Yeah. Apparently.
Little did I realize you needed 30 yeah.
We've stained from firing our weapons because the muzzle flashes would've marked
our position too clearly for the RPG gunners who had fired several inaccurate
rounds at us during the night. Fortunately, they hadn't come very close.
We played these deadly games with the enemy until sunrise.
At one point we broke a major thrust by tossing a white phosphorus grade
grenade. One of the most fearsome things I know of. We couldn't see them,
but we could smell burning flesh.
At around zero six 30 we heard an NVA officer or senior NCO calling role in the
distance.
Yeah,
it appeared. Few people answered him.
Okay.
As the sun finally burned off the fog,
we worked tactical airstrike with fandoms and sky Raiders.
A couple of machine gun positions,
open fire and hit one of the a one he is a fan of blue,
one of the gun crews to hell with a 500 pound bomb.
The a one he knocked out the second one minutes after it opened fire because
there were no more specter aircraft to call on.
I continued to working with a peer of [inaudible],
having them make run after run,
I could talk directly to the lead pilot and he and his wing man executed my
every
request or direction flawlessly. Damn.
You had to love those [inaudible] pilots. Finally,
we could hear in the distance the sweet, sweet sound of approaching helicopters,
big hh threes churning their way our way.
It was time to pull out all the stops.
I used every available support aircraft f fours and a one [inaudible] to raise
hell and suppress enemy fire as they roared in with guns blazing.
We could see the hh three's tagging along and they're awake.
I told Covey to have the hh three gun crews focus their fire on our southern
perimeter and we'd handled the northern side.
I also requested they land as close as possible to the north slope and not pay
any attention to the claymores explosions we'd be setting off.
I didn't want to spook these guys off,
so the the Hilos land,
every one of the team wants a board immediately went to the starboard window or
faced out the tailgate and began firing on full automatic as the HH threes
revved up to full power. I was the last to leave and before heading for the LZ,
I set off the last claim where we had put on the northern perimeter.
Then I ran like hell bent over like a cripple and cursing the prop wash that was
trying hard to push me backward as I made my dash.
I remember being surprised and not seeing a single dead body,
although I passed a slew of blood trails and saw a lot of dark wet stains on the
ground. The second I was through the door, the hh three lifted off the ground.
There was nothing but sporadic,
small arms fire coming at us and in the end the extraction was relatively calm.
One,
it seemed as if the enemy was dispirited and just going through the motions.
[inaudible]
I had a feeling they wanted us out of the AAO as badly as we wanted to leave.
Nonetheless, we all continued firing on full automatic.
We also launched at least one m 79 round. As we gained altitude,
I dropped my last hand grenade into the under Bush,
a little something for someone I hoped.
Then just as suddenly and miraculously all gunfire ceased.
The only sound was that of the churning Sikorsky h h three engines and the
increasingly cold air rushing through the aircraft.
I looked over my shoulder towards Tsao who is retrieving warm air force blankets
for the long ride. When I made contact with him,
he gave me that quick nod of his and a slight smile.
[inaudible]
we made it again.
That's just, just this just an insane mission.
Oh yeah. And I'm sure you, you know,
why don't you just break contact and continue mission?
So, um, yeah. Crazy. They need to. Yeah.
I know that you're, uh,
putting some of these books on audio book we're working on in the process of
doing that. And these are going to be great when you, when you release those,
uh, I know you talk about in a little bit in the book you were put in for you,
you requested one of your guys be put into it for a silver star for this
operation Ed John Angle.
And then you got put in for a silver star as well.
And actually you're the CEO said he was gonna upgrade that upgrade,
which I didn't agree with, but I'm not going to argue either. Yeah.
It to a distinguished service cross, which if you don't know that what that is,
that's the,
the second highest and military award for, for valor.
And so, but, but at the same time, and again this is,
I kind of have to just tie this back into the book a little bit,
but you had been going through this kind of hassle with the commanding officer
about carrying the, uh,
carrying a new encryption device out until you have it for that mission.
And you didn't have it for this one. Correct. But you ha,
but then he started turning up the heat like, hey, you got to carry this thing.
And this thing is no joke. I mean, I was looking at, I used,
even when I got to the seal teams, we used a PRC 77 were those around for you?
Yes. What we started with. Okay. For the, for that, uh, encrypted transmission.
So there you go. So yeah, the PRC 77 is an old radio. It's an FM radio and it's,
how big would I say it is? Well, it's,
what's something similar to trick 25 yeah.
But I'm trying to think of something that of a civilian would know. Can I,
so I can describe it. It's like a big, it's like two lunchboxes maybe. Like,
yeah, maybe like a briefcase that's a little bit more square,
a little bit thicker. So it's like that maybe two shoe boxes.
So you like this better? Something like that. That's what,
that's how big a PRC 77 is. The K Y 38,
which is the encryption device is basically the same size as that. Right?
It's like again, and it doubles the weight.
You got to carry double the batteries.
It cuts down your range because it takes away from the penetration of the,
of the, uh, radio waves coming out and you had to carry the encryption,
uh, punch. Ugh.
So that's what you're getting told to carry and you keep coming back and saying,
hey, this isn't that great. Hey, we been trying and it's not working.
Um, you, you, you keep getting told, nope.
Carry it. Carry, carry. Finally, you, you, you say to your boss,
you say the commanding officer, hey look, I'll carry it.
But if we get in one of these bad situations, I'm going to destroy this thing.
If it doesn't work, if it doesn't work, I'm going to destroy this thing. Yeah.
And he kind of says, okay, whatever. You know, but you carry it. Yeah.
So you go on an operation, you, you and you actually,
we're going to leave it in the Hilos.
You asked the Halos to take it you and you asked them to come back and get it
cause it didn't work.
He said he loves come back and take this thing cause it's 50 pounds.
He has the weight and we had, I wanted to try, we were,
the target was the asphalt and there was,
there was something specifically in the asphalt they wanted us to confirm.
So I went in with a four team. The
theory being we'll go in light,
we can move quicker because the Asheville valley didn't have triple canopy,
at least the part that we were looking at.
So it's like single or double canopy and a lot of open areas because it'd been
so many bombs to had been eight camps that had been overrun, deserted,
and I'd been in the ash all we put the sensors in and it costs,
we fly over it every time. So [inaudible] generally familiar where we were gone.
So I said I want to do a four man team, please don't force me to carry it.
Well we've had to carry it. And that's when I said if it doesn't work.
So we went in and tried it. It didn't work charted a few times. Yeah.
And they wouldn't come back.
And you been trying it on other operations as well where we try to one as just a
complete failure by brought it back. And so this time you start getting tracked.
Yeah. And and you say, okay, now I'm not carrying this thing anymore.
So you put a third of my grenades. You put a thermite grenade on. Yeah.
So you put a front of my grade on it, you destroy it and
then you again by the skin of your teeth, you got,
you get you and your guys out of there.
And when you are coming back to you, you're flying back to [inaudible].
And just so you know how close they were.
At one point I'm looking to the north and I see a young face come through the
jungle at me within two or three feet or so.
So I can see his outline and I can see his AK is down.
He sees me and we just stop and look at each other and it's all through the
jungle. The grass. He backed out. I just kept my car at him,
but he didn't open fire and he was young. I mean a young kid would a gun,
he backed up, he went away. So I knew that this, okay,
this mrs now compromise and we hit the thermite.
Yeah. Like I said,
this is another mission where you are getting out of there by the skin of your
teeth. It's a damn miracle that you,
you bring all your troops back that you don't get overrun,
that no one gets killed. It's crazy. Yeah.
And they, the CEO was flying in the helicopter close by.
We asked for a tactical withdrawals, right? Yeah. He goes, break contact,
your team issue our favorite words. So we destroyed the, the uh,
the encryption device, Roger that sir. And we have more contact. Well his,
he finally ran out of fuel, went back,
we were on the ground for a few more hours. We continued to move,
but we hear more activity,
particularly at the B thermite at the damn radio.
I thought we'd be getting distracted. He didn't. So now they know where we are.
Cause anybody within 10 miles can tell. There's the third micro nade any ours.
It's those guys. And they were coming for us but there weren't a lot.
But we had um, a new cover,
erotic came out Dallas Long Street and we started running a ones across me
could, we could hear the uh, enemy to the west. And so the,
a made a couple of gun runs and the last gun run the pilot came in and then he
flipped his aircraft.
So like I'm looking at the awan making a gun run and early you could hear them
when they go by and how the aircraft makes these noises,
these cracked noises when the wings change and the whatever the structures in
the plane are. So I had heard him go Bob before this one. He came by,
he wants to make sure where we were. He came by so close,
I could tell you he was smoking a Philly shirt. He looked over,
he nodded,
I saluted and he did a couple more gun runs and they brought in into s and they,
they [inaudible] couldn't land.
They dropped the ropes and pulled us out on ropes.
And of course whenever you go out in ropes to shooting matches like target
practice for them. How did no one ever get shot on the ropes? Maybe? Oh No,
we had a lot of gossip. Never got shot in the ropes. Not Go would just,
just luck. I'll share luck.
I mean I always felt like they're just coming through your legs,
get your balls or Mr. Happy.
Worse brain damage. I'm worried about brains.
Sure.
So you go through all that and again,
people need to buy this book so they can read that full story.
Cause even what you just said is a portion of it. Um, you get back,
you get taken out on strings,
which again is something we didn't talk about a lot,
but a lot of times when helicopters couldn't land,
they dropped down the ropes with the sandbags on the end and you guys were
clipping and they drag you out through the jungle and gets you up to out dude
and gets you out of there. And that's what happens here.
Finally you get back in here. We're going back to the book.
When we landed on the helicopter pad at CC and the CEO's biggest Renfe, a rude,
arrogant, or rude,
ignorant sergeant major told me to report to the CEO Asap with the k y 38 and
all attachments for it. When I walked into the CEO's office,
the ramp sergeant major ordered me to stand at attention, which I did.
Then the CEO asked the $64,000 question,
where is the k y 38 I explained to him that per our earlier conversation when we
had made contact with the NVA, since it didn't work, I destroyed it.
He flew into a rage telling me that I had violated a direct order from him not
to destroy it under any circumstances.
I stated once again what I had said prior to the mission because this was a four
man team. He simply said he didn't remember it that way.
It was just me, him and the ramp sergeant major.
Who knew that the CEO was of course telling the truth,
so the the, the sergeant major support and skipper, of course,
he's telling the truth. I didn't like the way this was going,
so as I had in the past with the CEO,
I tried to explain my actions from the position of the man on the ground,
which was different from a man singing a command and control helicopter as he
had earlier in the day while ordering me to break contact and continue mission.
Then he got really pissed and told me that he was going to write me up for an
article 32 crim criminal allegation onto them military military code of conduct
for willfully destroying US government property in direct opposition
to his order not to destroy the k. Why 38 under any circumstances,
the ramp sergeant major then whispered something to the CEO as they whispered
back and forth to each other. I found myself growing extremely calm,
unbelievably calm. Finally, the CEO step from behind his desk,
leaving the ramp sergeant major behind it.
I'm going to ruin your special forces career.
I want you out of CCN at firstlight tomorrow.
[inaudible]
he went on to tell me to report to Fifth Special Forces Group headquarters and
not train where he'd have me drummed out of SF within the next month.
Privately,
I smiled because the CEO hadn't done his homework.
He failed to realize that my service in the army ended in two weeks due to the
fact that I had extended my time and service to return to CCN.
The CEO only knew the date when I had arrived at CCN and had assumed I had a
traditional one year tour of duty that would end in October,
not April, 1970
my SOG days ended right there.
Yeah.
I knew that when I went to not training,
I could get any assignment in Vietnam where there was an opening for an
experienced SF soldier, but as I stood there,
I believe that God had sent this asshole into my life for a reason. Granted,
it wasn't a reason I didn't completely understand.
Granted it was a reason I didn't completely understand at this precise moment in
time,
but maybe it was time for me to get out of Uncle Sam's army altogether while my
body, if not my mind, was relatively intact.
Who knew what the future held for SF in Vietnam. Finally,
he finished and asked me if I had anything to say.
You're a disgrace to west point. Fuck you, sir.
I turned and exited without saluting the ramp.
Sergeant major caught up to me as I exited the door and told me to return and
salute the CEO. I bent toward his year and quietly said,
fuck you to sergeant major
before leaving the CCN headquarters area.
I stopped by the awards and decoration desk to see if the CEO had begun
paperwork for flying that day. East of our team,
embarrassed the clerk simply nodded his head in the affirmative,
meaning that the CEO was in the process of getting himself written up for an
award for telling us to break contact and continue the mission while he was
flying out of harm's away safely in south Vietnam.
That was him. Yeah. Wow. Oh yeah.
Just unbelievable. But you know, it's just like you knew it.
I just felt it. And plus he had had a reputation already by that time
and we had talked to the A and d people previously bought some other things.
He put himself in four.
Had somebody put them in four and a yes,
it's just a total disgrace and it's just the luck of the timing was the fact
that you knew that you could get out of the army at that point.
I was juggling the thought of re-enlisting. Um,
a friend of mine who was a captain who we have run one mission together. Um,
uh, he was gone.
He was in the process of putting me in for a direct commission to lieutenant and
a sort of paperwork had been placed. Um,
and I don't know if it ever got to Saigon or not,
but I know that he had a separate office. The paperwork was done.
We had completed everything, we had letters of recommendation, all that stuff.
And I'm so fat.
He and I talked about where we're going to do is I was going to stand for a few
months to see if the direct commission,
even though the reductions in forest were [inaudible], you know,
because they're already start the Vietnamization process.
The maximum manpower we had at Vietnam was at the end of 69,
I believe it was. We had 543,000 Americans in Vietnam.
So by April 70, when this all happen,
we had reduced the numbers. You could do more,
more what was coming even within SF. And so the,
all those things were being juggled. So if I got the direct commission,
I'd thought about that two years of college.
I knew I had to get two more years if I was gonna try for a career. And, um,
and I didn't want to go back to fort Devins. So, uh,
those were the things that I was juggling at the time.
And when this all happened, I just, like I said, I was really calm.
I just thought God gave me an answer here. Yup.
Going back to the book.
I continued down to the team room where it gave Sao $500 to buy food and drink
for the biggest party our t Idaho had. During my tenure on the team,
we partied late into the night one by one.
Each team member passed out until it was just hip and me standing outside our
Ti, Idaho's Vietnamese team room.
Hep asked me if I needed him for any more interpreting when I said no,
he passed out in the sand. I picked him up,
dust them off as best I could,
and carried him into the team room where I gently placed him in bed before I
turned the lights out.
I stood in the doorway for a moment longer reflecting on my 18 months with these
men with a special affection and admiration for
Sao Hep Foulk clang and hung.
Then the guilt pangs washed over me.
What did the future hold for them?
That had to be the hardest part of this departure. Ah,
brutal really was, and these guys
were just this continually for years, but they didn't rotate out.
No, that was their job. Well, hap had rotated up to headquarters, uh,
he asked for permission to go there for a better paying job and if the three and
a half years run a recon, so sure.
And we had the guy who was interpreter Virginia came over, not as good as Hap,
but he was a good interpreter. And by that time, uh,
we had worked on two other south Vietnamese [inaudible] and, um, uh,
chow were speaking good enough English where if I got shot,
they could pick up the radio takeover cause we cross train them on radio
procedures, slps, how to run, uh, everything. So, uh,
Hep knew how to do it then home and then chapel later.
And they must, from their perspective, this must've seemed completely insane.
Oh, absolutely. And they were like, really? But they knew the way,
but this is 70.
So SF had been near in force for six years by then and they knew enough and
talking to each other plus being in a secret war,
how things were operated and that, you know,
we all report it to a commander somewhere. And, um,
it was still one of the, uh, points as a sticking point was like, Oh God,
I'm alive, thanks to you. And now leaving you guys here. And uh,
so this is April 70 without a thing about what? April 30th, 1975.
It'd be like the date of Saigon Felon.
Just horrible.
So you, you finished with that, you know, you, you pack up,
you reported to not train during, during the next two weeks.
The most traumatic event was having the ice cream stand severely damaged by
enemy mortar fire. That was serious.
That's really messing with your head to destroy the ice cream stand.
The reps who had to go, God, they got PTSD from that one. Oh yeah.
They had to go downtown for their ice cream
on April 25th. So that was April for us. Now it's April 25th. Yeah,
I mustered out of the army at Fort Lewis, Washington again with mixed emotions.
I flew to Denver, Colorado to spend a few days with my sister Linda,
and to enjoy some spring skiing in the Rockies at the end of April.
She got a rental car from me to return to New York City.
I drove from Denver to Sutherland,
Ohio to visit my cousin Dunk Conrad and his wife Sandra before heading home to
Trenton. The drive was about 1300 miles,
including pitstops and a long wait in Ohio for food and few phone calls.
I made it home in less than 15 hours,
so you're averaging over a hundred miles an hour. Basically.
It's all it could do though. Let's just a rental.
When I arrived at 20 West Paul AV,
that's your house where you grew up?
It was around 3:00 AM times had changed in my absence.
My parents now walked the front and back doors of the house,
so wearing my jump boots and classy uniform,
I went around to the back of the house where I climbed up to the window,
grabbed the metal roof of the shed and stepped on the metal clothesline Hook to
push myself up to the red metal roof,
dampened by them morning moisture. After I climbed through the back window,
I went over to my little brother David and gave him a big hug. Hell,
he was taller than me.
Then I went down to my parents' bedroom moving first to my mother's side of the
bed. I touched her face but didn't say a word groggy.
She merged. She murmured. David, is that you?
Then she reached up to my face and felt my beard. John, she said,
has she stirred from her sleep? John, is that you, John Your home?
Henry. It's John. He's home.
She reached around my neck with the urgency and pain only mothers know and said
Johnny's home.
Oh yeah.
So you made it home
only by the grace God. And what came next? What do, I mean,
what did you do after that? Well, um, went to,
uh, went back to school cause it took me two years to flunk out. So that summer,
uh, I uh,
took classes and then my dad got me a job right away driving school buses.
And so like within the first two, three days of me getting a drivers license,
this is Trenton, New Jersey. There are still some race riots that were gone on.
So things were, they had a curfews, which is like,
this is like mind boggling in Trenton of all places. And so they said,
um, we got to run for you. You're going to go to Chambersburg,
which was the Italian section of Trenton.
And they were just starting new integration program.
So I picked up a bus load of young black kids that were mostly elementary
school, pick them up, take them into Chambersburg on the way in.
There's protests and I'm getting rocked in stone and I don't have my car 15,
because those Italians or whoever they were,
they were hitting us with those rocks. It was really make me very unhappy.
But here it was like, this is trend.
I'll go from one more zone to this and they're doing this integration style.
So the curfew.
So we had all of that going on and within a couple of weeks the church softball
team was reactivated a softball season was there as a,
did that school does some driving and uh,
eventually got involved in the school newspaper, became editor. Uh,
we had a period of time where the student government voted itself out of office.
We had the SDS on campus.
The calmness were in there doing her thing behind the scenes.
They burnt down a couple buildings just for good luck,
played dominoes in the library, knocked over all the books, their stupid stuff.
[inaudible] and then was you w you had to just be thinking to yourself, oh,
are you serious? Yeah, absolutely. What I just, you know,
saw my friends get killed, took risk my own life.
Saw what the Vietnamese people were actually fighting for what they wanted.
Yeah. And you had these people back here in America do it acting like this.
And the student, you know, we knew the SDS was,
we're back with the calmness and they had their order propaganda,
but it was never reported. They were just like, well,
here's like another group protesting in the streets without any kind of active
deaf,
deaf definition as to who these people really wore and what they really hated
America. And so, you know,
we're evolved with school trying to get gone and um, you know, during this time,
um, we got very active with the paper and it was editor for two years.
So I've worked on a paper for every day for two straight years. And uh,
we had our moments, you know, they had the first faculty strike in the state.
So before that I was really excited could me and two other SF buddies were going
to shut the campus down cause the,
the faculty there and the teacher unions told us we will support you students
and we're going to get things for you. And they made other promises, which,
okay, I'm all for it.
And it'd be the first strike in history in New Jersey.
And so me and the guy has put together a plan because there's basically three
major entrances in one couple of clandestine routes.
So we had everything planned.
We were going to overturn an empty fuel tank or at one gate,
the other gate we were going to just close it down with cars and things.
So would take them at least a day or two to clean it up and clear it out.
We shut that school down so we're putting our plans together. Right.
So now here comes Mr editor.
I get a copy of the state.
I go to the State Department of the higher education and a chance to give me
what the state is proposing says, look at this, read this.
It says have the union give you their proposal,
but they wouldn't give it to me nor would the chancellor.
He felt it was a violation of their fiduciary.
Whatever the hell was that they are dealing with these union people.
So the union guy had his Volkswagen in a parking lot.
Long story short, I borrowed his contract,
I got it photocopied it while I'm photocopying it downstairs at the
administration building. He walked by, I salute say hi,
continue to photocopy his is a negotiating paper which has many pages long
[inaudible]. I went back and print them side by side.
There's two mentions of what the union was going to do and over 20 or 30 pages
of documents.
One was to give them more time off and the other was for class size as all they
had in those pages. We printed it,
did an editorial and said screw the Union and opposed it.
And then we went to war with the union editorially and the Finnair and they went
on strike but they didn't close the campus down. I pulled up,
pulled our true brokenhearted man cause I really wanted to get some,
some goodwill of warfare here at Trenton State College. You know,
they lied to us. What were you studying at the time? Um, well you know, uh,
I was a member, I was a freshman,
is 64 and I finally graduated in 74 with a political science degree with a minor
in English because English was still my foreign language at the time.
And did you, did you, I know you were working at the paper again,
that's what you ended up doing for your career yourself?
Career must have my amazement. Um, you know, cause a w at the signal,
that was our school paper. I did everything, photography, editorials,
new stories, and uh, went down to the Trenton Times a local paper.
They were owned by the Washington Post.
Dick Harwood was the editor and during the war to gates stuff,
he was the voice that was skeptical of Woodward and Bernstein.
But he was my editors. I go down and I went in for an interview.
I said, I had my hairs on my shoulders.
Now I hadn't had a haircut for a couple of years. Blue Jean Jacket, t-shirt,
jungle boots, old blue jeans going for the first interview. He's interested.
Just come back for a second. I went back for a second interview,
had a clean tee shirt this time. Stepped it up. Yes.
I'm thought I'll pause in the jungle boots. I said, Nah. So I got hired,
went to work the trend times.
I was there for 10 years and then went to San Diego for 10,
10 years with the San Diego Union, which is about eight years.
Moved to California in 1985. What made you decide to move out to California? Um,
the Washington Post sold to Trenton times and the quality of the newspaper just
diminished incredibly.
I was fighting more with the editors to get stories into the paper because I
covered the courts and I was doing an investigative stuff.
We did a story about the, we broke the story about, um,
the FBI investigating Philadelphia Police Department corruption that went to the
top why I had interviewed a marine who was a Vietnam vet,
who was the undercover guy working with the fan belt inspectors for 18 months.
I see. As Guyanese we did this today, we did this,
he made fun of the FBI and so he told me when they're getting ready to,
to go out, get the search warrants and do to rates,
I called up the fan belt inspectors and said, hey,
heard you got a little case going on.
I don't want to jeopardize your investigation,
but I'm going to write about it before you guys do it. Let's talk.
Turns out the chief FBI guy was a, uh,
as a spectrum pilot. Oh Geez. He had flown in Lagos.
Now we couldn't determine if he was my savior that night.
On February in 1970 or not. But we had an interesting exchange.
So I gave him two days and they put all the paper together and they put up
wiretaps on a key suspects and the Philadelphia Police Department.
Monday morning, our broke the story scooped the Philadelphia Inquirer.
Every major paper in the world is before TECOM just news network and Fox News
and all this stuff did the story. And uh, it was amazing.
And they, and they did the whole thing to follow. So that was my,
one of my major coups.
We had the other story about the Philadelphia Phillies that were under
investigation. So had, uh,
law enforcement with my f was my main source that I did the courts.
And in between we duties investigated pieces for fun. Came to San Diego,
was there for eight years doing law enforcement,
covering our beloved border patrol. And then from there went to North County.
Uh,
and I always lived in North San Diego County and they had a paper called the,
uh, the Osis side bleed citizen. So I went to work there.
The editor's job paid $10 a week more than a reporter's job. So I was like,
became an editor's assistant city editor up in Oceanside,
which eventually became the North County Times.
And so I went to work there in October and met my, uh, future bride in December.
She had, uh, two boys. I had two girls.
10 months later we're married.
And so we'll be celebrating our 25th anniversary of this, uh, this October. And,
uh, we moved at a tie breaker. So the tiebreakers,
he's 22 now and I've worked at the paper until, uh,
2008 that I've worked at a couple of nonprofits helping veterans over the last
11 years in between that, a couple of books for good luck.
Yeah, yeah. Well, no awesome books. It seems like,
and this is something that I was like, I obviously, you know, you,
you went through some just completely insane, intense stuff. You come back,
it seems like you got back into society fairly well fairly quickly.
You and, and what I always say to guys is like, you need a new mission. Like,
cause what happens when I think guys fall apart is when they come back from
wherever they're deployed to and they don't, when they come back,
they don't know what to do. They don't, they don't,
they don't go on to the next mission. Whereas you're like, okay,
I'm gonna go to college.
I'm going to work at the newspaper or I'm going to organize these, you know,
we're going to fight this fight.
And it seems like you got focused on what your next mission was. Where,
I think that's when a lot of guys don't do well.
And I was wondering if you saw anything with your friends,
other Vietnam guys that you served with the guys that seem to get back on track
and carry on with their life as opposed to guys that don't.
Yeah,
Ma majority of our guys I like to think came back and the adjusted one way or
the other. Oh, we had a couple of tragic cases that did. And I mean, uh,
when I went back from my second tour,
I went back with Jeffrey Jenkins who was going back for his fifth tour duty,
second or third with SF. And so we held on the plane going across,
went back,
we land in a Cameron Bay and steady going through the process.
We got our duffle bag, went out, stole jeep,
drove to a the Trang but didn't go to headquarters,
went downtown and partied for a little bit.
Then we poured it in the Trang and then went up to CCN there cause we were both
returning, so was no in country training on Esta and uh,
and my order specifically said
Cs CCN and I got back to the team right away, which you covered earlier.
And the other sidebar, which really helped was um,
at trench state college,
I point it was a point man for the POW Mia Concern Center.
They came out with a bracelets and a, the whole thing would,
there was that effort, they had American citizens that were,
and the family members,
the first time American family members petitioned an enemy to treat our
prisoners better. And so our prisons weren't related,
released until February of 1973.
We had two years that I worked at the POW MIA concern center.
We had appealed w and air force POW from Trenton. We supported him,
his all his family wrote letters,
everything we could do a for now in our spare time between classes,
putting out newspapers and things like that.
So it was like a really a sub Rosa mission. And, uh,
when the prisoners came home, that was just a great moment. And so,
but it really was helpful.
Like they set another mission that we went into the newspaper going into it.
And, uh, there's a period of time to student government voter,
Sada self out of office. So the paper was the only student voice.
So we took a,
what's the deal? What do you, what does that mean?
The student government voted themselves out of office. What does that even mean?
Hey, this is 1971. We had, uh, people that were just,
uh, too busy. They didn't think the student government was, was, uh,
could address issues.
They're apropos to true needs of students or whatever the hell that meant.
And I forget the real reasons, but they just disband themselves.
So the signal was the only voice on campus.
And so we became much more active. And of course we had a fern of action.
It was starting then and uh, the teacher strike,
we had a outbreak and meningitis were killed.
Three students had to cover that. And of course,
deep in my mind I wanted them to strike.
I wanted to go out and shut the campus down,
but it didn't work out.
How about the, uh, you know, how was it the treatment, you know, um, you know,
as a modern day veteran myself,
like we get treated just unbelievably, ridiculously good.
Whereas the benefit from Vietnam, we weren't treated well,
but today our citizen tree treats our soldiers,
sailors appropriately regardless of the politics. Yeah.
They thank you for the service mostly. Yeah, we had, we had cases, I mean,
I w I wore my fatigue jacket for years just to say, fuck you. I'm wearing,
if you don't like it, talk to me about it.
And we had a few parties with the newspaper.
And so everybody,
almost everybody except for one or two people were very liberal courses.
This is the college, 1971 too. And uh,
we had this one freak is like six, three,
he had his long hair and he came up to me, he said, you know, you guys,
I know about you, green brace, your fucking baby killers, you know,
you've gone on to whole Party, comes to a stop. So it's mean is creep.
And so he said a few more things and in fact he says,
aren't you really a baby killer? And I said, look,
the only time we killed babies and when we ran out of rations,
well he just, it was never hit. That kid was never the same.
And every bosses kind of like laugh and realize how ridiculous this asshole was.
So it's like, why get your hands dirty? Yeah. Yeah. So yeah,
we had someone at like Lynn Black, when he came back,
he was trying to get out of the airport quick and took a, took the door,
got outside and wound up in a long corridor. Well,
three or four guys came up to him and said, hey man, you're back. You got cast,
we're going to believe you. That burden.
So Lynn pulled out his 25 caliber browning, the little ones, you know,
you put it in your palm and lingos no you're not.
I'm not giving it to you. And the guy goes,
I recognize a cigarette lighter when I see when Lynn put her mouth between his
legs right there at the airport day they left. But again,
it's no respect. You know, Linda's didn't want to get his uniform.
Where was that? Where it was Lynn [inaudible] up in Seattle. Yeah.
Yeah. And then
how did you start getting reinvolved with like, uh, the,
the special operations group that you're with now? I got a phone call from us,
but, well, there's two. I got a phone call for spider parks in 1983.
I lived in Trenton. Um, my first wife, first daughter,
and uh, he said we got this group Special Operations Association.
It's our guys who was formed by Green Berets that ran recon.
And we have some hatchet force guys.
They were the platoon company size operations, like mad dog, Cherry Shriver.
And uh, they had formed up, um, a few years earlier.
So I signed up Bob and Linda to Trenton and there were unions were at different
places, so I'd never, I didn't bother to go for several years,
but spire and I talked, pay my dues and finally went to,
and he started having him in Vegas. Me and Jeff junkers would drive,
go to Vegas, get into the hotel, wait to security guard,
left and sneak into the reunion, hang out with the guys for a day,
pick one of our guys,
crashed in their room for night and then drive home next day.
But we get to see the guys and no money. We get to free food,
free drinks and a little gas. Right? So we did that for a couple of years.
It was a lot of fun. And then, uh, when I finally met Anna,
my s my current wife and my sweetheart forever, uh,
that kind of came to a close.
I took Annan one time and the first time was not a really completely good
experience. Some regards is still pretty wild. And the hotel wasn't that cool.
But now it's more of a, our guys a Sloan now a little bit.
We've lost some along the way, so we haven't to be union.
This will be our 43rd reunion that I'm also involved.
The Special Forces Association, Chapter 38 up in orange.
And I went to the restroom two years ago. At Christmas time I came back,
I was president, so I'm wrapping up my,
my second year duty with those gentlemen.
And, uh, what's the, what's the, uh, the nonprofit group that you have?
Oh, we have the veterans, um, uh,
veterans affordable housing program that's out of orange.
And then we have a separate, uh, uh,
nonprofits called the American Veterans Assistance Group where we work with
programs within our communities.
We have 45 communities in the five western states that are, uh,
are owned by our company and by our nonprofit. And so, uh,
we encourage to help veterans that have fixed income to get them into affordable
housing. You know, the manufactured homes are less expensive, the stick houses.
And then we have programs with, through our, uh, the vag program.
We have programs for meals,
meetings have been a guest speakers and things like that.
And we're doing antebellum non of our communities now.
So that's where my other jobs than do the newsletter. Busy.
Always, always busy. Can't like twenties was a kid. Let the old man in.
Well, I'll tell you what, um, we're,
we just had three hours or something close to that. So, uh,
I know I need to let you get Outta here obviously. Um,
anything else? Any other closing thoughts? Uh, no, just the,
as I said to first time as I could have done any of the books without my
sweetheart, my dear bride, you know, we had a, uh,
14 pages in and the, and relatively newborn in the house, she said, go right.
And God bless her. Without her, I couldn't have done it. So,
and it found me today, we just learned we got to, to grow.
Two or three girls are pregnant. So we're getting excited about being a,
grandparents are practicing and we're still work with, are nonprofits.
So moving forward,
anything can people donate to that nonprofit? Do you have that kind of thing?
Is there a website or anything like that or is it you guys just run it locally?
No, they uh, I'll have to check the website, but they could, uh,
um, I've got my email,
my website saw chronicles.com and they could punch in near my emails there and
I'll put Klan, the Ford and the uh,
uh, we're going through some changes with our website redesign.
You know how that goes at SOG, chronicles.com is how people can talk to you,
reach out to you through that gladly. And Yeah,
come on in and we'll say hi and take it from there. Awesome. Awesome. Well,
well thank you for this opportunity and your books be, we love,
thanked me at all.
Absolutely says this is the honor is 100% and completely all mine, uh,
to hear the stories,
which are completely insane to learn from your experiences. Uh,
obviously, or maybe it's not obvious.
Anytime you want to come on the podcast and you shoot me a text,
you let me know and we'll just open the door. You can come in.
I don't need to say anything. You can just talk. That's fine with me.
I'll just listen like a bad dream. I'll be back.
I look forward to every second of it. Likewise. And you know,
so thanks for coming on and you know, more important and of course,
thank you for what you and what your teammates did for the service of our great
country. Likewise, sir. Thank you.
We're always indebted to you and men like you.
So thank you for what you've done.
Appreciate it airborne all the way until next time.
And uh, once again,
John Stryker Meyer tilt tilt has left the building.
What an incredible human being and it's a complete honor and just lucky to be
able to sit here and talk to him and hear his stories and hear him reflect on
stuff. And it's been awhile. It's been three hours.
So anyways, if you liked this conversation,
this podcast that we just did, if you got something out of it,
which I know I did, if you want to support the podcast, sure.
While you actually support your own self,
I think echo can give you some help in making that happen. Yup.
Yes. So let's go into it. Obviously you do too. If you're not doing Jujitsu, I,
I would say Jocko and I strongly recommend,
I thought you were gonna say we were disappointed. No, see yeah,
maybe, maybe part, but not really.
At the end of the day there was some understanding to be exercised here cause
not every, okay, you were rolled, you're different.
But sometimes people roll into Jujitsu gym or see it on TV or even think about
it. Two people wrestling all hard or whatever pit.
Some people just don't automatically want to go do that and you know,
just automatically on its surface you might think,
oh well that's not really for me.
I don't really want to grapple grapple with some other dude.
What you don't see is what's beneath the surface cause what's beneath the
surfaces. Fitness, flexibility, mobility.
Mentor.
Stamina. Yeah. Physical Stamina. Yeah.
Cardiovascular improvement. Strength Improvement on top of all that.
You guess what?
You get legitimate skill that you can actually choke another person that's
bigger than you, that's stronger than you. Yeah. You can take them. Yes.
So, and you know, if I speak for myself,
the reason I started in continued with Jujitsu because it's the skill that
you're talking about that you learn that skill is this.
If someone, if someone insists on fighting you, you can win the fight.
You won the fight. And before you learn how to fight,
and I'm speaking generally speaking, um, before you learn to fight,
you think, ah, you know, I'm all just do this. [inaudible] you know,
I'm stronger than that guy or I'm bigger than that guy. Whatever. Yeah.
You know, and you don't realize how, how untrue, how,
you know how I've said we lie to ourselves. Yes. Like we lie to ourselves.
This is a whole nother category of lying to yourself.
Cause the one category is like, we lie to ourselves like, oh,
it's just one donut. It's not that big of a deal. That's just a lie.
You aligned yourself or, well, I don't,
I can't make it to the gym today cause you know, my, you know,
it's getting a little late. That's a lie. You know, it's a lie,
but an even bigger lie is I'm more capable.
I'm capable in certain situations and you're not and you think,
and you still talk to people like this boy, like, oh, you know,
well if it really came down to it, you know,
and I lift too. Yeah. And I got strong cardio.
Who's going to be able to take me? I'll tell you,
most 14 year old girl that knows how to, you know,
choke you. Yeah, that's true. Yeah. Just like in Pool, right?
You play pool billiards, billiards, snooker. Sure.
And it's like, yeah, I know. I see what's going on.
Hit this ball to get that ball and go on the thing that's no problem on some
money on me. I'm pretty smart. I'm pretty coordinated, you know? I'm just like,
that's just how my mind, how hard can it be? Exactly. Right.
And you go play against the guy who really, who knows how to play pool.
You'd be like, Bro, how do you even do that?
Like how did you even like figure it out? But they know. They just know.
It's not like it's this magic thing.
They just sort of know the same thing what you did too. It's like, man, in fact,
it's such a mystery when you actually do it, how easily they beat you.
It's such a weird magic mystery that you don't even comprehend it. Yeah.
At first you're like, oh, oh, oh I just slipped. Nobody.
You didn't slip people either butchers. Yeah, yeah, yeah. When you think,
oh well next time I'll just stop them from putting his arm there.
He's got 1 billion other things and he's going to do, yeah, exactly. Sure.
Know nothing about. Same thing with basketball,
the way that's the same thing with all sport basketball, right?
Well yeah, it goes deep anyway. When you do Jujitsu, when you dude,
you get to, cause you're doing it, we're doing it and you're gonna do it.
You should get a g cause you don't, you want to do g n No-gi.
So the kind of game that you get is an origin g Beski in the world factually and
made in America, which was a huge deal by the way.
Also origin the brand that makes these gies they make jeans.
American denim. You didn't get yours yet, did you? No, I didn't. I totally,
him and I talked to be little all the time. We just got his, yeah, we showed up.
We know why we take care of the customer first.
Well you're not really the customer mind or t,
you know what that is a research and development test and evaluation.
Testing quality assurance. Yeah.
And I just got another test evaluation for the next phase. Yeah,
cause I'm making another phase.
We lie to ourselves as a wise man. Once that anyway, no,
I don't have jeans, but I, from what I imagined and from what I see in gather,
you know from the field, they're good jeans.
See now what psychological good flanking maneuver you just did right now.
Then I'm just saying Brian will hear this and they'll be like, oh,
echo doesn't even have jeans. No, no. I'll get a hundred percent better.
Get them to them? Nope. Did you, did you text them and say, Hey,
can I get a pair of jeans size or whatever?
Me and Brian share text and paint by the way, how like, oh,
we're the last one.
We're the only ones that we literally know that don't have the genes and then so
he texted me the other day or show or even worse,
takes me in the Instagram story about his jeans and you know me, I'm over here.
Well then again I wear the shark fin short, you know,
what do you call the shorts that they make? That's all I wear.
Whatever hep presenting. Representing big time.
But they happen to be the best shorts. You wear jeans very often. Me? No, not,
maybe that's not why you're too vocal about it. Yeah, maybe.
But you would be if you had them on.
If I knew like maybe I'm just sour grapes, like I don't even want any. Cool.
All right, well I do have them. All right. How are they? Are they good?
They are totally good to go there. The next level squared away. Awesome. Yup.
You can get jeans, you can get t-shirts, you can get supplements.
We have supplements, we got, we've got joint warfare, which you should take.
We've got killed Krill oil. We got discipline and discipline.
Go discipline goes like get your
cognitive wheels spinning, turning, moving quickly.
Sharp. So can we have discipline going to can come out?
I think he's actually out right now. Yeah, the little, yeah.
So those are the same formula. The one, the test one that they they, yes. Okay,
good. Yeah, that's, that one's good. Yeah. Here's the thing. All of these,
right? So you have joint work for Krill oil, right? The Combo.
That's the best way to go. Fleet and joints and stuff. And then, you know, uh,
discipline and the Malkan and everything. Can't consider this. Right?
As you get older and you still want to fight, cause man,
I gotta I gotta be honest with you. Um, you know, you feet,
you know how you catch the wave of just consistency.
I know you're a consistent person and discipline. I've been on that wave. Okay.
That's a tsunami, right? So you're the, you're the poster child of [inaudible].
I do have the Ding knee right now. Yes. Which is we're almost there.
Yes. But you know how, okay.
You know how some people can catch a various levels of,
how should I say, flourishing flourishes of activity, you know, um,
where they'll catch the wave of consistency meaning like everything they're
doing in their life is like I'm being disciplined and I'm in the zone where it's
like just second nature now pom pom, everything. Right.
So if you take all of these supplements that's gonna keep you on there,
especially as you get older. Oh,
I don't know about the older part cause I'm just kind of the same as I was
always just is how for you, but take it from someone who's getting older,
actually getting older. Uh, these, I think I, as far as my workouts,
like they're hard.
They're harder than most of the workouts I did when I was young and I'm just
maintaining big time as far as like staying in the game.
I'm saying check anyway. You get the consistent Combo. That's,
that's in my opinion how you do it. Also, I mentioned milk,
additional protein in the form of a dessert. Straight up.
There's a delicious drink that's says so tasty.
It was telling me like they were saying, oh, it was Dave. Good deal,
good deal. Dave was saying,
he's at a point now where he's drinking strawberry milk.
He goes, listen, it's one thing to be okay,
it's time for dessert or hey, I'm a little bit hungry.
It's another thing to just be sitting around or walking into your house and bds.
Just think for no reason other than I want to taste the goodness.
I'm just going to go have this strawberry milk,
strawberry slayer right now and you know,
I understand because I've done that before and this is what I thought.
The thing is you, there is no guilt in that, but here's the thing.
The concept kind of made me feel a little bit guilty when I was doing that
because you know how the kind where you're just like at home bored and you see
the cookies and you're like, it was an easy path and you took it. It was a,
it was a desire that you should come to that my hand be a bad pattern to go
down. Yes. So you gotta be careful. Don't get,
don't allow the goodness of milk to start to train your brain to accept things
that you just want. Yes, you can make an exception with milk. You can be like,
Hey, I really want this right now just for just for the sake of wanting it. Yes,
you can let your mind, but don't think, hey donut. Yeah,
there's a slippery slope bro. It is that good. That's kind of shit.
That's true. So just be where the mindset essentially there's other flavors too.
If you don't like strawberry, which some people don't. Who is it? Jason Gardner.
Jason Guard. Jason Psycho. Like shrubbery. Good job. Jason. He's over there,
but he, he takes that little, hit her with his coffee in the morning.
He's got his little, he's got his little ritual scenario. Yeah,
he's got going on. That makes sense.
So strawberry and coffee I can ask from Red Cross is known right now. Like the,
the the one Yulia there. Yeah, sure. Then you got mint peanut butter.
The peanut butter is also off folks, so it was the mint.
That's the re that's the old baby. Did we just say, Oh gee, yes we did.
We did big time. It is. And then don't forget about the warrior kid milk.
Which the word getting milk for your kid.
Either that or you can give him poison. Yeah, you can give him poison, which Oh,
you got a bunch of corn syrup in this drink.
I'm going to give it to my child so that,
so that I give him type two diabetes or you can get them something that makes
them stronger, smarter, faster, better, yes. Or your kid or your kid milk.
Strawberry and chocolate gets on also Jocko White Tea, certified organic.
Very good. Micro, how would I even call it? Micro doses of caffeine.
There's like mini mini doses. Yeah, it is. Yeah. There's 60 milligrams per cam.
It's Sorta like a cup of coffee.
It also has the antioxidants in there and also days refresh. Very.
So there you go. And well obviously obviously.
Yeah. If you want to dead lift 8,000 pounds, obviously. Yes. The TACO. Yep.
That's the one also certified you also,
we have a store. Jocko has a store. I say we have, so we all have a store.
If you want to get your merchandise. I haven't said that word Merck.
I don't really say that word that much. Just said it.
And you said it in a real kind of explicit kind of way.
Cause my daughter watches youtube videos, which I had to block her. Hello?
Not Blocker, but you know,
you know how you got to put the block on youtube so only they can only see
certain things. Anyway, I had to do that. She's like, you're like, okay good.
The only thing she's allowed to watch is two Jitsu videos,
Jocko podcast for your kid podcast. I don't know man.
She didn't take it to anyway,
the reason I did that was because she was falling some girl on there who was
really, she was just real sassy. She wasn't,
it wasn't like derogatories and she just had a Sassy way of talking.
Maybe 15 maybe 16 years old young man. That's my estimate.
And my daughter's six.
So this girl is talking about this and then my daughter is starting to say this
stuff, which is cute at first in my opinion, but after a while you're like, hey,
you can't talk like this is not yes is not what we're doing over here doing
exactly right. So she, anyway,
so recently within the last past two days, we had to block her anyway.
One of the things she kept saying was like marriage and she'd say it all Sassy,
like I'm not going to do it again. I'm not going to say it again.
But that's how she was saying it and it just slipped into your head slip.
Right and slip right out of your mouth right now talking about the murder.
That's why that's so what can you get at
[inaudible] dot com store Jocko,
store.com this is where you can get discipline equals freedom shirts,
lightweight hoodies, which are really nice, man.
I had it on the other day and every once in a while I'll flash into it and be
like, Hey, this is, yeah.
You know what's interesting about Jocko store.com what's that?
Is we sell tee shirts. Sure. For one thing,
we sell discipline equals freedom t-shirt. We sell good teach, we sell t-shirts.
There's also people that come up to me and say, oh,
I just got an awesome tee shirt. I got one of your tee shirts. And I'm like,
I sweet man. And I just had a guy say to me, hey,
I just got one of your tee shirts. I wish I was wearing it right now.
And I was like, cool. And he goes, it's the, uh,
don't talk, just get after it shirt. And I go,
cool man. We don't have that. I don't even have that shirt.
So there are, what do we call them? A knockoffs, knockoffs,
shirts, what do you call like, yeah, there's like a word for it.
So yeah, they're disapproved, but they're kind of worth calling and approved.
They're like, worth this is why, because people will,
they don't know the layers.
You know how like remember the layers on his shirt and you have paid $90 for it
and has no layers came with no layers. There's no layers, man. And that's bad.
That's really loose and it's a piece of crap shirt. Yes.
So it's kind of like when you buy something for the kid,
you have a reason to buy something. Right. And this is generally speaking,
I know different reasons vary from person to person,
but you have a reason you buy something, right?
Let's say there's two reasons to buy a shirt. One of these shirts,
let's say there's one reason straight up, one reason.
The main reason is the layers. You get. Anyone literally you can spray paint,
discipline equals freedom on your shirt. If you're on display,
you can have that on. Yeah, you can do that. Totally can.
You can have one printed, you can go to a website and whatever font you want,
you can make it look however you want, literally. So why won't you do that?
Right? Cause you want more than just that.
There's something else for whatever that reason is. You're in the game.
Whatever that reason is. We'll call it x reason x. If you go by,
stop talking, get after it shirt. You literally bought something else.
You didn't buy an x check you out thinking about this one,
you know, because there's a whole reason I was thinking about it but,
but nonetheless, here's the thing. No Sir. No,
because I saw some kind of creator.
You feel like people are kind of
no maybe, but in defending you in this way though, because there is a,
there's a shirt thing called like t red spring or I don't know,
something where basically you can go online,
take a jpeg of a picture.
I can get any one picture of you online, submit it to this website.
It will make a mock up of the shirt. Like the, you know, the cheap shirts,
you know the buy buy in bulk,
maybe secondhand whatever shirts make a mock up and be like,
hey goes by my shirt. Right.
And I saw your face on it and it was like kind of a literally the wrong design,
right? They were trying to copy. Exactly. But there's like already seen this.
Yes. I saw, this is a while ago and I saw it and I was like, man, you know,
down in TJ, like they'll knock off like Louis Vuitton purses and stuff.
At least it looks like the Louis Vuitton logo, you know,
and you got to look close to see the, you know, the, the, the quality,
the lapse and quality. But this one was like flagrantly wrong design, you know,
whoever. Meanwhile they're like selling it like their thing. Yeah,
it was offensive for sure.
And it's offensive on two levels because offensive tenet to us it's like, hey,
that's not our stuff. Don't misrepresent a B. The person who doesn't quite,
you know, they're just new and fired up. They can be like, hey, there's one,
here's the first one that popped up on Google.
They're going to get the junk one.
They're going to go out and try to represent in the wild and that's just not
going to work. Man. That's a bummer. That isn't, there is no support,
no support. And you know, I get it.
Support isn't the primary reason when you think about it,
like you've got to go out there and someone buys a shirt they want around their
no, but that being said,
there are some people that they don't really need another shirt there literally
just to support. Yes sir. Plenty of people just chatter. Just hey,
we appreciate the time, the effort, the whatever. Appreciate it.
Here's a little thank you. A little supports. Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that. It's appreciated. That's w that allows us to,
that allows us to have echo, make all these videos
nonetheless. The Jocko store know who's listening to this right now.
No one with three hours, three, three plus hours.
All right. Whenever you're going to say you might as well say it. No one cares.
It's all still true about that and yes, the Mitt,
the stuff that you really want to represent the authentic certified,
there's no certification process but approved. Approved, yeah.
Is All on Jocko store.com I w a active dot C O.
Dot. UK that if you're in the UK, that's where you get it. Yeah. So I,
and here's the thing I'm saying, when you say this, another URL for that,
well it's dot code that you, you can still yeah, that's,
you gotta be like that. Okay. Anyway, cause you know,
cause shipping certain parts in like the pay,
the shipping is crazy from here is what I'm saying. So boom.
You wanna you want to sidestep the shipping a little bit. You can do that.
Might take a little bit longer. I think. Maybe, I'm not sure.
I don't live in the UK, but nonetheless, some people were asking me about that.
Oh yeah. Anyway, hoodies and stuff. All the legitimate approved stuff.
Check it out. If you like something, get something.
Also subscribe to the podcast. If you haven't already on iTunes, stitcher,
Google play, wherever you listen to Plat, uh, I,
I tuned or whatever you listen to podcasts. That's what I meant to say.
And the warrior kid podcast, which is not, it is not dead, you know,
which is more episodes are brewing. They're brewing in my mind.
Should I, you know what I make for the warrior kid podcasts I do last,
I don't know, six episodes perhaps. I've done the story from Uncle Jake. Yeah.
That takes not just time cause it takes a little bit of time to prep,
but it also
takes the spark of inspiration. Right. Okay. Here's the deal. Right?
And you can't manufacture Inspirado knows. We know. So sometimes I'm like,
well I could just do a QA for the kids, which is what it started out as,
which is fine. Which I get it. So,
but sometimes I feel like I'm letting everyone down if I don't do this story
from Uncle Jake's childhood.
Cause I really liked doing the stories from uncle Jacob Childhood. So do I. Now
I will, like I said, we're back on it.
Maybe I'll release some with no story from Uncle Jake's childhood just to,
cause I get so many good questions from young warrior kids around the world and
I mean that, think about that. The world little warrior kids all over the place,
getting ready to get up and get after it. Do some pull-ups. So yeah,
take out the warrior kid podcast.
And also if you want to support a actual warrior kid, go to Irish oaks,
branch.com where young Aden is making soap that allows you to stay clean.
Check. Also, we have youtube channel chuckled podcasts, youtube channel.
If you're interested in the video version, we're gonna see what Joe, what
John Stryker Meyer looks like. Tilt, Aka tilt or if you went to a Jocko,
looks like if you don't already know more,
if you don't have a shirt with his face,
Ari on it and you wanna see what he looks like on a, you know, youtube.
And also there's some excerpts on there you don't have,
if you want to listen to or revisit specific ideas or or concepts,
lessons you know individually and share him with your friends,
you don't want the higher likelihood of them watching it.
That's where you get them on our youtube channel. So yeah,
echo thinks his videos are good. You can leave a comment on his videos.
He does read them. I read them all legitimately.
Everyone likes to say that echoes. So check that out. Psychological warfare.
That's an album with tracks where if you've got a little moment of weakness,
you might be approaching and you want to get out of bed or you want to get your
workout done or you want to say no to a donut, donuts,
press play. Psychological warfare, iTunes, Google, play MP3.
Don't forget about the visual version of psychological washer warfare from
Dakota Meyer, flipside con canvas.
Dakota Meyer is making art.
You know that you can hang on the wall that says all your excuses are lies.
It makes all kinds of cool stuff. He's stepping up his game with that.
It's really cool stuff and if you haven't listened to podcast one 15 with Dakota
Meyer,
check it out and then go get some of his gear from good old flip side.
canvas.com yes, that's a very good one.
I was talking with both John Bozak [inaudible],
Phyllis Aka illustrator of where a kid book series and like in the dragons like
no word he was talking about. Yeah,
I got some good stuff that you know I'm going back and forth with Dakota Meyer
way, so he's going to be designing some of those. Yes,
we have some of that school. Your kid posters, canvases,
wall hanging stuff from Mikey and the dragons,
which might be the dragon's artwork. Let's face it. This stuff is legit.
You consider yourself kind of an artist, right? Yes, I do. Yes you do.
Pete Roberts just over there creating color palettes. Yes you are.
I'll see you over there with your color palettes. Your point, sir.
My point is that we have to admit that Mike and the dragons art work is awesome.
I will. We're taking it,
we're putting it on to some legit size canvases and you can hang it up in your
kid's room so your kid learns to overcome his or her fear
check. Agree also on it.
So on [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko so this is where you can get any kind of
fit, like additional fitness gear, awesome fitness gear, including kettlebells,
which I recommend. Battle ropes, maces clubs.
So I've been talking to some of the guys there.
He was telling me about the ecosystem.
Mace or a club in both. Right. Which one is the one with the longer? Is Mace.
Okay. Yes. Club is short. Yes. The Mace. So I was like, yeah, no, I, I don't,
I don't really do that workout.
But I looked into it and how it might be beneficial. The Macy's,
even when I official, yeah.
Well the Mace and they're both beneficial.
The thing that's beneficial about them, they're awkward. Yes.
They're hard to him handle. Yeah. You know,
I've been doing like a lot of kettlebells,
like heavier for as many reps that you know, it's like that guy.
You know how there's different, you know,
you can do like Kettlebell for a long asked anyway.
The more awkward kind of the thing. And you've been doing those sandbags too.
Huh? You're soon, man. Those awkward.
Here's a good exercise with the sandbag. You just take your sandbag,
just heave it over your head, turn around,
heave it over your head and turned around. He weighed over your head.
That's actually tiring.
You're going to find that to be more tiring than you expect.
Especially cause the first one you're like,
Oh jack was said this was going to be tiring. It's not.
Then you do the number three and you're like, jock was not the number five.
And you're like, why am I breathing hard?
And then you do it like seven times. You're like,
why am I even doing this because it's too painful.
That's my experience nonetheless.
I been doing it and consistently kind of for the first time in life or it'd be
like,
Oh yeah I tried to work cause it's cool for a week or two and saying it's cool
workouts, good workout, I get it.
But I've been doing them for like long time now.
Kettlebells like these awkward thing and in Jujitsu I feel this,
it's not weird. It's weird cause it's new.
So it's this new like lack of tiredness.
You know how there's like different tiredness in Jujitsu where you're like,
okay I'm winning. You know various people, you know. Yeah. Not You,
your knees out. I get it.
And you know when you come back we can roll or whatever.
And maybe I can really put my non tiredness to the test. But like I'm saying,
you get few different types of tiredness.
You're like, oh, that has nine like 150 different names for snow.
You have different, different styles and tired. Negative. No, because there's,
oh, think about it. There's the contentedness where you're breathing real hard,
but you can still generate kind of force with your muscles. You know,
your muscles aren't like Noodley, but you're like, oh,
you're not a muscle failure. Yes. Which is different. It's different.
And they would call that type of tired muscle faring, muscle fatigue,
Eskimo words for all these different things.
All your different forms of fatigue anyway. Or you can be like, Dang,
I'm not breathing hard, but I just, I'm just so weak. My body,
I can't lift my train with me. How much have you trained with me? I don't know.
Infinity Times. What? What? How do you describe my tired.
All right. Here's the, I'm trying to think. Have you ever seen me get tired?
I have with me. No. No. I've been tired. I'll tell you there's,
there's a couple times I totally remember getting tired. I was,
we did Nogi holiday training here.
One time we started with No-gi, we went to g, we had six,
I think it was six 10 minute rounds. No, it was six,
six minute rounds. No-Gi six six minute rounds,
G and I was tired at the end of that. Everyone's, you know,
everyone does the leg.
I'll take a rest round and then I'm going to go get Jocko. Yeah.
I'm just tired fully. Nonetheless. I didn't,
after doing all these workouts, I don't feel the like body tired,
you know, like a dog. Don't feel it. It was like not even nearly as well,
like I really got to get pushed to fill it, but so anyway. Anyway, the point is,
yeah,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash chocolate look at all the cool stuff on there.
Grabbed something from there that I don't really help you.
I'll keep you in the game. Big Tour books. Jocko. What do we got?
Got a bunch of books. Goodwill, where there's a will.
That's the latest way of the warrior kid book where there's a will getting some
really good reviews from people. I'm one of them. Have you finished it yet? No.
Oh, you're still working through it, Huh? Anyways,
if you want to help your kids or any kids that you know get on the path,
these are, these are books that everyone tells me and I will tell you,
I wish I had these books when I was seven years old, eight years old,
nine years old, 10 years old,
100% where the warrior kid Mark's mission and where there's a will check them
out. They're in multiple different languages to check that out.
If you speak a different language where your children speak a different
language, you can get that. Also got Mikey and the dragons miking.
The dragons is the book that should be read to every kid at least once a day
from the ages of one until six. I agree.
I just read it in a first grade class.
You went in the first one to a first grade class and read it.
How'd that bad happened? I went in there. I got nuts.
I told all the kids, cause you know it's like they're trying to,
their goal of a is to keep the kids calm. Right? I come in there, no,
that's not happening.
So I'm like good morning children and like there are good morning and I'm like,
what? Good morning. What? I can't hear you. What?
I'm not sure what you're saying. Can you please be loud? Are [inaudible].
So they're amped. And as I was getting them all amped up,
I started getting nervous cause I said, wait a second,
I'm getting these kids completely just jacked up and getting crazy and hyper.
And then I'm going to expect them to sit and listen to me read this book,
which is a 15 maybe an 18 minute read. It's not, it's not short.
It's not short. And so I was, I was like, Ooh,
I might have overstepped my balance. I might've done,
I might have made a broad tactical call.
So then I crack open the book. And this is after, you know,
answering a couple questions. I crack open the book, I read it, boom,
silence and total attention for 18 minutes. While I read the book.
So that book, and I was to explain to the kids that I put,
I put words in her, I said, listen, there's words in this books that you,
when you read them,
people were saying that words too big of a word for a little kid. I said,
these people want to make you stupid. I want to make you smart.
When you see this word, and I opened up poised, there's a thing, right?
We use the word poise. I rhyme it with noise. And I said,
these people don't want you to know what the word places.
And I read it to them again, that little section. I said,
what do you think that means? And you know, some little kid, little,
little Billy up front. Is it mean like he said something really smart. He says,
does it mean you keep your feelings inside? And I said, yes, Billy.
That's what it means. Don't let the man keep you down. They want to see,
they want to give you the dumbest book. You can read this books,
got a couple of words. You're gonna, you're gonna have to,
you don't have to try and figure out what they mean, but you will poise.
You just figured it out. Billy, you set an example for everyone in this room.
Salute. Salute William.
I know that's advanced man. So that's Mike in the dragons.
Get that for the library. This is what you did there.
That was my theory. Hypothesis, you know? Okay. So you're, you're,
I made you train to the next belt level up. Yeah. Okay.
No, with, with, with the kids, when you're getting them all fired up,
here's what you did. You didn't necessarily get them,
you said there's a difference between being loud and fired up and being at
attention. So you got like the,
the trouble from what I understand that teachers and babysitters are way,
if you're looking after the big grand coaches and stuff like this,
looking after a big group of kids is, they don't, they're, they don't,
you don't have their attention. Yeah. You're fired up.
And a lot of the time with kids,
they're so fired up that they can't give you their attention.
It's going everywhere. Yes, exactly right.
So what you did is you just basically wrangled like a big horse wrangler
wrangled, all of that fired up in this,
that these kids in there actually have anyway,
but you got their attention so they'd,
you didn't have to like go against the grain with them at all.
All you did was sort of funnel it, funnel it you,
so all that fire does towards you.
So when it was time they'll do anything you say.
Now you're telling me you actually,
you've actually seen firsthand and the effects lasted like weeks after the
wreck, which is weird. I'm going to show you both videos side-by-side. Yeah,
that's right. Yeah. Okay. So I'm going to tell the people if I haven't already,
I dunno. I might have said [inaudible]. Okay. So we're at, uh,
Dave Burke's house. Good deal. Good deal. Do FERC. Shouse exactly right.
And we're leaving. It's time to leave. So it's like my kids, my two kids. Um,
your kids were not there. One of my kids, my youngest. Yes.
Your younger youngest was there. Um, Dave Burke skids,
Jamie and Flynn Cochrane's kids. And who else was there anywhere?
It was a lot. This is a lot of kids and jock was there.
You did the exact same thing.
They did the exact same thing with them as you did with the kids in the class.
See, I see what you're doing there now, which is good by the way.
So you're going to detached. I like it. Detached.
You're giving your assessment and I have the video to revisit two.
I have one and my wife has one. So my wife's one, she's videoing you and your,
it cuts in where you're going like this.
You're going go go hookah with your hands site to site.
You're going to hook a hook, go hoop. The Ha and the kids are trying to keep up.
They're like, oh, what are we doing? Okay.
And slowly they started doing it and you're like,
and then you start yelling at them. You're not doing it loud enough. Yeah.
And then the same thing who go and they all start doing, they fall in light,
they're doing it louder or whatever and you're like louder.
Of course they want to be louder so they get so they can and they fall in late
and they do it. You're like, good. And then you give them high fives, right?
Good job. You'd want high five, you're like harder. Give one,
high five just whichever random kid please say harder and then they hit you with
a harder high-five. Then you go ah,
real loud and you go mean of course that gets everyone else fired up like they
want to do the same thing.
So you're like going from kid to kid high five saying aw mean and everyone's
trying to do it harder than the last kid or whatever. Meanwhile when other kids,
if you notice when other kids are giving you high five,
the ones that are not giving you high fives are just watching full attention.
Just waiting, waiting for the next thing.
Now the point of this story that made a significant to me was because two,
not even two weeks later, let me be like a week later, right? My son who's two,
my daughter who's six, my daughter accidentally,
and my wife has this on video too,
cause they're playing and doing little dances, whatever on accident.
My daughter steps on my son's wrist just on accident when they're Kinda,
you know, in the scramble. So my son gets up, he's like, he goes, ah,
and hits my daughter. Right.
And goes mean like, what the heck? That was kind of weird, you know,
that was a weird outbursts right there. So I'm like, cool. And then,
but my wife clever, she kinda remembered something about it. Right.
So she revisits the video that she took of you going, ah, I mean,
so it was like a hit and then I'll point on, right. That's what you did.
They hit in your version with a high five. Sure enough,
I see my son's little head watching the whole time, just in the corner.
He didn't do any highlights.
He was watching the whole thing. Go revisit my son daughter's virgin,
same exact thing. Boom. Incident, right steps on the wrist.
Instead of high five he does a hit to her shoulder or whatever in a high five
fashion and goes mean the exact same tone is you.
Your children are always learning. Yes.
So if you want your children to learn properly, the right stuff. Yeah,
read them Mikey and the dragons. Yeah,
but see what you did there with the attention. Rightfully it's,
it's totally effective. That's a good note, man.
I'm going to tell you that's a good little anecdote technique.
I'm going to use it. I'm gonna use it. Check. Don't do it before bedtime.
By the way, don't forget about the discipline equals freedom field manual.
This is the graduation gift, right? Get it for your kids.
What are they?
1517 1922 the 24 getting done with their master's.
Get them to discipline me cause freedom field Mandel, they got work to do.
We all do. If you want it on audio, it's on iTunes, it's on Amazon music,
Google play and all that.
Then you've got extreme ownership and the dichotomy of leadership written both
by me and my brother Leif Babin.
They are books about leadership and they will give you some principles that you
can apply to every single situation you are in,
in business, in life, the economy, leadership and extreme ownership.
Speaking of life,
we have a leadership consultancy and what we do is solve problems inside
organizations and we solve them through leadership cause that's where the
problem is. So it's me, it's Lafe, Bab and JP Denelle,
Dave Burke, Flynn Cochran, Mike's Really Mike [inaudible] and Jason Gardener.
If you need help in your organization with leadership,
go to echelon front.com and also we have EMF online
because leadership training is not an inoculation. It's just like Jujitsu.
You can't just show up one day. Now you know Jujitsu. You can't just show up,
read one book and or go to one seminar and now you're a good leader. No,
you have to continually train and that's what ETF online is.
Interactive Leadership Training, new modules coming out monthly.
It's got me and the rest of the Ashkelon Front team working with you to give you
pragmatic skills. Go to [inaudible] online for that.
Also the monster Chicago done.
It was sold out next up Denver, it's going to sell out Sydney, Australia,
December 4th and fifth the Denver one is September 19th and 20th go to extreme
ownership.com if you want to come to these events because they are going to sell
out,
so go there early and ETF Overwatch where w when you're looking to hire someone,
don't think,
oh I've got to find the person that has the specific skills that I want.
No,
what you want is to hire the right person with the right kind of character and
the most important skill that they can have is leadership skills and then you
can teach them the technical skills that they need to know for the job.
We have people with character and with leadership capability from special
operations in combat aviation and we can put them into your organization.
It's our company F Overwatch.
It's an f overwatch.com if you need leadership in your business or team and if
you want to hear more from myself and Echo Charles,
we're on the interwebs, we're on Twitter, we're on Instagram and we are on
Facebook. Echo is adequate. Charleston,
I am at Jocko Willink and once again, thanks to all the veterans out there,
men like John Stryker Meyer who fought for the American ideal and who himself
represents that ideal, true American hero,
humbled to sit here and talk to him and to those of you that are out there on
the front lines right now,
thank you for fighting for our ideals as well.
And also thanks to police law enforcement, firefighters, paramedics,
EMT is dispatchers, correctional officers, border patrol, secret service,
first responders.
Thanks to you for living a life of service and sacrifice so that we can live our
lives in safety and security.
And to everyone else out there, remember
John Stryker Meyer has written about and told us stories that he lived through
and some of them are just hard to believe.
I don't know,
but also remember that for every story of bravery and heroism that he tells,
there are an infinite number
of stories that never got told
stories from the men who did not come home,
soldiers, sailors,
airmen and Marines who gave away all their stories,
past, present, and future.
They sacrificed all those stories, the stories of their lives
for us.
Never forget them.
And until next time, this is echo and Jocko out.